good morning
welcome everyone to house ways and
meanings committee and we will now open
up the public hearing on how spill 639
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative Jason Osborne
good morning everyone I'm glad to see
most everyone remember to set their
clocks
um I know I almost didn't luckily these
newfangled phones they do it for you so
alarm went off as a as anticipated uh
it's my pleasure this morning to present
House Bill 639 for the record Jason
Osborne representing Auburn um
Candia and Deerfield they changed my
towns sometimes they're hard to remember
relative to the legalization and
regulation of cannabis I see someone
brought us some samples over on the
table there
um so I hope you all enjoy
uh I just want to give you a quick
overview of where this bill came from
the Commerce chairman is coming up right
behind me to talk to you a little bit
more about some of the details that we
did over there to some might say refine
others might have other words to
describe what we did
um if you remember last year uh we uh
uh chairman Abbas sponsored a
legalization bill that was uh quite
different than what we have attempted in
the past it uh possibility of running
Cannabis stores uh much like they do uh
with liquor today and if you'll remember
if you were around last year there were
very few of us who thought that was a
good idea the reason we did that was to
appease some other
um
people that are in the legislative
production chain if you will and uh it
didn't didn't quite work so this year
um over the summer a whole group of
interested parties got together to put
together uh the first draft of what you
have in front of you today and
um people from the industry uh people
from the recovery Community
um uh you have AFP on one side the ACLU
on another side everyone all working
together to try to
um you know solve this problem that
we've been going back and forth on for a
year after year after year I'm sure you
you know the the house routinely passes
some kind of Bill like this every year
in the other body uh routinely shuts it
down and uh so we would like to get get
this solved once once and for all
so what we did uh uh in Commerce uh we
kind of
have applied
um
some of the objections that we heard
from the other body last year
in that uh
things like they do not want to see
people growing uh themselves at home we
are
uh strongly convinced that that would be
a deal killer so that's out we don't
talk uh in this product
um about annulling past offenses uh
that's a a topic that can be left for
another day
um the other uh big change two two big
changes one uh
the idea that was presented by the group
over the summer was that we would form a
brand new commission kind of like the
Liquor Commission but a commission that
would deal just in in
and uh it was the uh the thought of the
the Commerce Committee that I'm sure
that the chairman will talk to you about
that um
uh why reinvent the wheel we've already
got a commission a Liquor Commission
that's more than happy to take this on
and
um and rather than approach it like the
sale of liquor like we did with the bill
last year instead we're kind of treating
it like we do tobacco where we license
uh businesses to uh to sell and as well
as uh cultivate
um
and so
we we hope that that addresses the
spirit of what was desired by giving
control of this new industry over to the
Liquor Commission but um overcoming the
issues that
um some had with it
including myself such as uh not having
the state itself run
the stores and not employ the people
selling the product
as well as having to front all the money
to build the stores right so there's no
there's there's no money allocated uh
for for building new stores it's all
around regulation licensing
the other big uh change that we made was
around the taxation uh the the idea that
was brought to us over the summer was to
attach cannabis to the rooms and meals
sales tax
and uh there are various reasons for
that uh
one would be that there are a number of
legislators who don't like creating new
taxes myself obviously included
um and so the idea was well if we just
attach it to an existing tax then we're
not creating a new tax
um I I think at least speaking for
myself
you know that
you know you you don't need to find me a
loophole to to uh pretend like I'm not
creating a new tax when I am so um no
matter what we do we are going to be
extracting new Revenue uh from the
industry because it does not exist today
and I would look at it as um
you know not creating a new text but
replacing one because whether you like
it or not there is a tax on cannabis
today and it's an enforcement tax
because it exists in the black market
um the uh cost is baked in to the price
of the good of having to deal with
avoiding uh law enforcement
it's just a simple supply and demand
analysis right
so what we said was uh you know we we
also know that the the
um
the other body I won't name them uh it
does not like
um
meddling cannabis with the rooms and
meals tax the feeling is I've it's been
described to me as
the more things that we add on to that
tax the more it makes it look like a
general sales tax and people don't like
the look of that and I I can completely
respect that
so what we did was we we looked at our
surrounding states how they do their
taxation we thought well why don't we
just do what Maine does and then you
know cut cut it in half and then we said
uh well why why make it that complicated
let's just have one single
tax on the cultivation level and the 15
that we came up with
would be about half of the total tax
that our neighboring state of Maine
charges so um
so that's a basic overview I know you're
here to talk about revenues and and
whatnot so um
um
I would say uh whatever whatever uh you
guys uh do with this uh Bill going
forward my uh strong uh desire would be
that uh that we keep in uh compliance
costs and uh taxation as low as possible
right uh the the primary goal here is to
eliminate uh the black market to take
these products out of the purview of
gangsters and Thugs and put them into
the legitimate Marketplace to keep
people safe and uh and to keep them
these products out of the hands of
children
and keep adults who are using them as uh
as safe as possible and you can only do
that in a um in a transparent and uh and
well-regulated uh market so I'm happy to
take any questions if you have any or uh
let the uh the smart people go
thank you representative questions yes
representative ulery
thank you for taking my questions my
understanding that one of the the
biggest uh Revenue generators so the
edible con um
cannabis products and it seems to me
that on
page three
uh the definition of cannabis doesn't
include uh
uh cakes or or Foods or food ingredients
like that or even a cannabis infused
drinks so
our Edibles does this bill only apply to
joints or does or blunts or does it
apply to Edibles as well and where where
am I missing that right if you skip over
to page four there's a definition of
cannabis products
well that's regular your but you're
defining cannabis as not including and
then you're defining it as including
okay I I hear that someone else can
answer this question thank you
representative fellows
thank you madam chair I'm wondering if
you can speak to the um production train
chain that you're envisioning because
when I see that the proposed tax is on
the wholesale
product I'm not clear about where that
would be in the chain of developing the
products
uh yes I I will uh let someone else
speak to that as well but um
so there's a there's a cultivation then
there's Manufacturing and then there's
retail so this would be as it uh is
transferred from the cultivator to the
manufacturer
representative horse
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question is there a reason why
we didn't tie it to the tobacco tax or
is it because of Maine's 30 percent tax
um
so I don't know why we uh didn't uh
look at the tobacco tax in relation to
this but uh I think the the um
the thought process was uh start with
our neighbors and then cut it in half
okay
other questions from the community
thank you you say tax as little as
possible but you're using the 15 which
seems to be the highest number that
in the things that I've read that people
are using outside of California which is
not selling very much marijuana because
of it
no I I hear you uh but um you'll see
that these other states they have
multiple taxes at at all different
levels of uh the production so the 15 at
the wholesale I believe if you were to
convert that to a retail tax would be
something less like six and a half
percent
just off top of my head
follow up on it's actually a separate
question have you talked to any calls
calls has the committee talked to any
cultivators
yes well that's interesting
so have I thank you
representative ulery
uh thank you for a second question and
maybe you can't answer this book but
it's my understanding on the federal tax
regulations that if the state Takes Over
Control of a controlled uh substance
like with alcohol
as an analogy then
none of the well not them none of but
the prohibitions that the federal
government has on individuals engaged in
this uh kind of uh disappear is
is that the way it works
I I don't understand the question well
because you can't take uh credit card
transactions or debit card transactions
because they go through a federal
banking system
to in order to purchase some marijuana
product it has to be a cash product
but if the state takes it over would
that prohibition go away would there be
some better uh I got you I I'll I'll
punt that question as well and I know
that there's good answers coming up for
that
representative Ames
thank you for your presentation and uh
what I was particularly interested in
and I'm particularly interested in as we
look at the bill is the movement from
our rooms and meals tax to the tax on
the at the cultivator level
um and why and you you spoke to that and
it has to do with the senates uh wanting
to get this by the Senate as I
understand it what I worry about is
whether it will it will work uh at the
cultivator level and I wonder if you've
explored that at all are you or you
share that concerns that's the concern I
will be
looking at as we go through this yeah I
think the main concern off the top of my
head at the cultivator level is what
happens when it is
the barriers are broken down federally
and now the product is being shipped in
from Iowa yeah and then how do we how do
we handle that and
that's an interesting question yes I'll
be happy to hear what you come up with
you thank you
oh representative
yes thank you madam chair
so if we're legalizing this
in in allowing people to sell it we're
taking that sale out of the state's
control
why tax it at all
I mean these people that are selling are
going to pay business profits taxes
business enterprises taxes I mean this
additional 15 percent I mean couldn't
couldn't we conceivably make an argument
that the businesses that are selling
this are going to be wildly profitable
and we're going to get our money
in a different way
I like the way you think representative
um I happen to agree and uh if if you
could find me uh you know 201 votes plus
another uh 14 votes plus another uh
Governor
um I I would love to go along with that
10-4
all the questions for the representative
seeing none thank you for your testimony
okay the chair will recognize uh
representative hunt
welcome
thank you good morning I am
representative John Hunt representing
ringe and uh again I would say I I've
never done this before so this is this
is very interesting process uh generally
when Commerce passes legislation we
generally do not have any new taxation
involved or new revenues involved having
said that I would say that uh this is
the first time that this legislation has
come to Commerce and uh
the way we looked at it in Commerce is
that our most important is not to
reinvent the wheel and that we did see
that we somewhat have the the model of
the Liquor Commission and our liquor
statutes
um and for better for worse I'm I have
to admit I'm one of the few people who
understands uh the Byzantine stack tax
structure uh and revenue structure of
the Liquor Commission and but it was
really important that we did that to
apply to this legislation
and having said that many people think
in terms of the liquor stores
and how that back when our forefathers
in 1934
created the commission after the
prohibition was repealed and their mind
was uh that the state should make the
profit the stake should make the revenue
and that model would would it was
obviously working very well but it was
based on the concept that um
New Hampshire didn't make any distilled
Liquors at the time
and uh but other states did and other
countries had wine
and so the idea was that the Liquor
Commission would buy it in bulk
and
sell it at retail and make a very large
margin
and that model is still true today
so when uh this marijuana bill showed up
in our committee the first thing I had
to learn is that no marijuana is not
coming from any other state or any other
country
like we would do with liquor it has to
be manufactured grown cultivated within
the state
so that means this legislation is not
only trying to you know is going to be
doing something different it has to
create whole new Industries
and and then figure out how we're going
to license regulate them and ensure the
same same goals The Liquor Commission
has always had and when we uh in a
little Side Story
um the commission is also in charge of
enforcement of the tobacco laws and yes
believe it or not I was the chair of
that subcommittee Donna scitec when she
was speaker asked me to steer steer that
piece of legislation through to have the
commission also is the enforcement and
it really made sense because most of the
tobacco sellers were also selling beer
and so therefore the two goals that we
have is which is not to serve anybody
who has over consumed
and more importantly not to serve it to
anybody under 21.
and taking that same goal same ideas of
what the commission does it made sense
for us to just add this new category
the legislation when it came over
created a whole new commission whole new
enforcement division whole new regulator
and and the Commerce Committee says well
you know that's that's Reinventing the
wheel why why would we do that we
already have a Commission Now who again
they have you know the deputies they
have the hearings process they have all
those things already in place and the
enforcement to ensure that our licensees
comply why would you go out and create a
whole new new entity
but we knew we could not use the liquor
the the distilled wine model
because it's all coming from in-state so
then we looked over at the other model
that we have and that is how we deal
with beer in the state of New Hampshire
I go back to 1934 the wisdom of our
forefathers who at that point said well
we're just going to draw a line
and whether it's the right line or
number it's certainly been changed over
time but we're going to say anything
that is six percent or less alcohol
is going to be called a beverage
and it is not regulated to the
Commission in terms of the commission
selling it but the the commission still
is uh enforcing the licensees
and is taxing it
the tax right now is 30 cents a gallon
and that is gallon not dollar value
which is interesting because I remember
when Steve Allen Court put in a bill
that said that we should be taxing it
based upon the value because he says
beer nowadays is getting more and more
expensive and we're leaving money on the
table because we're charging you know
logger we're charging the same tax rate
as a as a as a custom Brew but that bill
died
at any rate so it's always been 30 cents
in all the other states around us have
the same basic model of of a gallonage
tax it's not a very high tax
but what's interesting about that tax is
that that tax is collected by the beer
distributors Who are the middlemen
and we actually have in our statute
right now
we have a requirement that any licensee
that can be other whether you're an
on-premise or off-premise licensee any
licensee has to pay their bill their
beer bill
within 15 days
and the you know this means the state is
actually creating a statute that
requires you know so I'm going to have
to pay their bills on time and why well
because in that tax in that bill is the
tax
so this is nothing new with the idea of
requiring somebody who's an integral in
the process to collect the tax
and have it built into the product
so now we get to how we decided to do
this at the conservators level
okay if you say well this compared to
the Beer model or the beer model was the
beer manufacturer makes that beer but up
until I passed a legislation many years
ago but allow beer distributors allow
beer manufacturers to self-distribute
believe it or not when we first created
the law for more than 40 years they had
to go through a distributor you a beer
manufacturer had to go through a
distributor uh and maybe that's because
the distributor was the one who was
collecting the tax I'm not going to say
that's why but that's just the history
notwithstanding is that when we changed
the law and we are now allow
beverage manufacturers to actually
produce actually that you buy a beer
right there at their location
uh yes they're now collecting that 30
cents a gallon tax and on top of that
because they're serving it to a customer
they do have to pay the the meals tax
obviously marijuana is not going to be
that way you cannot consume marijuana on
location we will never have an
on-premise licensee with marijuana
but what we can say is if you look at
the three tiers ironically it's three
tiers is that we have the cultivators
which are the people who are growing it
this is the most highly regulated
manufacturing business New Hampshire
would ever get into the ball in in terms
of who these people are one way they're
doing it because you know literally many
states they actually have a little bar
code around every plant
okay now I don't know if we're going to
get to that point but the key element is
the commission is going to ensure that
that marijuana the Integrity of that
marijuana being grown is maintained
inside that cultivator level
the cultivators will then sell it
in bag form or whatever in Bud form and
that is the manufacturing level
the manufacturing level can make
brownies oh they're gone
brownies they can make gummies they can
roll joints they can do anything they
think in terms of
packaging the product
the product is then
taken from there to a retailer
we do actually have in this 3G air we
have one another license in between
there we do license the trucks there
will drive it deliver it
okay but we do that now with our
beverage manufacturers we actually they
get a separate license to deliver it if
they're going to be self-distributing
but here's the kicker
if you tax it at that cultivator level
we'll call it the you know the
manufacturer that base level
now you get it before shrinkage
we're gonna tax it right up front right
from before it leaves the door we're
going to have that tax
uh I don't know if we have it in the
rules now but maybe they'll get paid
within 15 days by whoever's buying it
the manufacture or whatever that they're
going to get paid in a timely fashion
but we're going to tax it at that
beginning level because let's face it
there's going to be shrinkage when they
when that gets out of there in that form
the bud form and gets into the kitchen
or wherever this you know whatever these
processors or whatever they're doing
back there's going to be shrinkage
we won't care because we'll have gotten
our tax up front at the cultivator level
when we looked at this these numbers
what other states were doing and we say
and and I couldn't believe it some of
these states are doing it by weight okay
30 cents a gallon okay they're doing it
by weight
well you know let's face it weight you
know can be how much moisture was
involved in the room or whatever but the
idea that you know now we need to bring
uh the department of weights and coming
in not only we're going to check out gas
pumps but you know scales and
restaurants by now we're going to check
the scales and how there's I mean oh
come on
that's that is not the New Hampshire way
of doing something we want to keep it
simple and straightforward so this way
we're doing this is that 15 tax is on
the wholesale price as it's then sold
to
the middle the manufacturers the
processors
so we're going to get the full value
we're going to get our 15 we don't care
what they end up doing it the
manufacturer might
put a little away they might do who
knows what they do how efficient they
are I think they'll be pretty good at it
I don't think they're going to want
shrinkage but there may be some but more
importantly by the time it gets to the
retail level
it's already for the better word it's
already taxed is already baked in
and now all our retailers can advertise
that it's tax free to the consumer
not that that was important to us that
was not the governor the governor that
on this that made the most sent to us
sends to us was they're going of all the
licensees the one you're going to have
the least amount of licensees
is going to be the cultivators
and in this way we know those
cultivators are highly regulated we're
going to be keeping a lot of eyes on
what they're doing and what's going and
out of their buildings and so they're
because they're so highly regulated it
really makes sense for them to be the
one that collects the tax when they sell
it as a wholesale product to those
manufacturers
the only other thing that I think my
this committee might have of purview
over is the fees of all these different
licensees and at this point and I'm sure
you all know this and that is that the
fee any license fee should be a true
reflection of the departmental's costs
to provide those licenses it is not a
profit Center
so therefore we don't know how much the
fees the licensing fee should be at this
point in time because we don't know how
many people are going to be getting into
the business we don't know the
denominator the numerator we still have
those numbers to work for and those are
in rules in this bill
so that's a player to be named later
what those fees are I would say the
liquor in terms of the as the uh
legislature Commerce Committee we we
deal with these fees often enough to
know that it is a little complicated
because you want to vary the fee based
on how big of a production or how big of
an NT is so we actually
um you know have we we say if you're
only going to be making a very small
allowed amount of beer or a small amount
of wine or the sale that our fee is
little is less
then if you're a big guy so that's
actually also again reflected in what
will happen in the rule making at the
end of the day any new cost to the
commission
to implement this and enforce it will
obviously have to be baked into those
fees that will be determined later
and with that I will finish my testimony
that was very helpful thank you for
giving the broad overview and the
construct very helpful obviously we all
know that the construct has already
passed the house yes handedly so we're
going to be very focused on the revenue
and the taxation policy
can you talk to us a little bit about
where you came up with that 15 percent
yeah I was originally
um we were at more like 10 we were
looking at other states again we're
looking at they're doing it by weight
a lot of the states
um Maine because they allow have home
cultivation they sell the plant it
sounds the starts so we we're you had to
kind of go through all those different
what they were doing and how they were
doing it
um so it did seem that most you know if
you were to get down to it that um 10 of
the cultivator level seem reasonable and
then five percent at the retail level
now obviously
um
the retail level now that's gonna at the
retail price so that's you know the
margin from the wholesale cost so we
said well what the heck because of this
idea that it's much better to tax it
when we know we're getting the full
product
untainted not worried about whether it's
you know got sugar mixed into it because
it's a brownie or or a gummy or whatever
that by taxing it at that cultivator
level at the wholesale level
um it seemed that that a a good Revenue
number is just to take that five percent
move it over to the wholesale level now
obviously that's not true the same but
again it actually gives a little bit
more Revenue but then when we start
applying that 15 and comparing it to
other states it was clearly that it was
it was half of what other states are
collecting overall thank you one other
question I have before we send it around
um where's the money go
so in the Builder has different sources
of where we where we spend the money
um and uh I mean obviously I I I have to
admit we did not Commerce did not touch
that piece of the bill
that was what came forward from that
committee that was created to push the
legislation
um in the way we looked at in Commerce
was it should really just be pulled into
the same funds the way the Liquor
Commission is which is
um obviously that's General funds
um but then I guess in this legislation
it does talk about funding the pension
State Pension Plan and but always in any
case there is money carved out to deal
with drug abuse and helping people for
recovery so that is in this also in this
legislation
representative Ames
hi and good morning good morning Dave
um my neighbor to the south of Jaffrey
almost immediate neighbor
so uh
my question has to do with the revenue
and uh
we have you know the 15 tax in this bill
we have a the only uh
fiscal impacts
uh piece that I've seen was done by dra
various other agencies but dra was the
only one that looked at the tax issue
and it looked at uh rooms and meals tax
correct and um have you seen anything
has anybody done a uh an assessment of
what the 15 percent might uh
um I do know the liquor commissioner has
done some more details on those numbers
um for just you know discussion purposes
so we compare ourselves to Maine
um you know they were their their sales
um they were bringing in close to 20
million dollars a year to the state
follow-up I guess it's not as a second
question well I'll ask it anyway
um
the uh the other question is um
uh yeah it's uh it's not the fiscal
impact yeah it's this question
um you said that this will be a tax on
the wholesale price as sold to the
process processors
um
and I guess that's okay it actually
speaks of gross revenues uh
realized by the processor it would be
the subject of the text but um what I'm
wondering about is how do you determine
that in the case of a vertically
integrated
um Enterprise that's got all elements
you know right that's why we're going
right to the beginning okay the the
cultivator the only thing the cultivator
is producing they're not doing it
they're not processing it now if they
decide that they do they want to say
they want to be the full tier which back
in their forefathers didn't let that
happen with a three-tier system but
let's say we did then it simply as they
they have their calculation of how much
they're Distributing it to the their
other division that's processing it and
so that is where the tax would then be
collected
where was in a plot
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I got two actually
what is Massachusetts judge
um less I have to I mean it's a little
Community because they do they have they
have multiple levels of Taxation plus
they then do a sales tax on top of it so
it's all over the it's it's multiple
levels of Taxation I I can't but it's
it's more than 20
20 and then when you add in the sales
it's going to be close to 25 percent
I forgot the certainly just so you know
I just was handed out uh some fiscal
notes so I will pass those out in a
moment um but we'll continue listening
to this representative representative
thank you ma'am sure thank you chair
you're welcome
it must be high because there's a whole
bunch of rank here
um
just to characterize the taxation scheme
you would reverse that be a good because
you're you don't have the step by
step-by-step tax increase you've got a
tax
and then that tax is divided across all
the products that are made so we have 15
cents here by the time it gets down to a
single item
it's a division of a division of a
division of that 15 cents
applied to the product would that be an
adequate characterization I had when I
was thinking of my testimony I was going
to bring up the vat tax and I said well
that's I don't want to get in it's I'm a
little convoluted but I realized that
this is wasting means so you guys all
know what the vat tax is about but uh so
yes you're you're you're correct and
ma'am sure my other question
the the other question I ask is
you're
defining cannabis in one place and it's
not a food product and then when you
define cannabis products it is a food
product but you're using the word
cannabis and when you define the word
cannabis it excludes food and then
cannabis products includes food we need
to get some
uh if if there's some clarification
there I I certainly now the problem we
had was it was an early bill so we were
somewhat rushed to get it out so I know
that they're I've heard some some typos
and some references that need to be
cleaned up but which I have I would we
would consider that a very uh germane
Amendment
other first questions representative
fellows
thank you madam chair
good morning hey Sally nice to see you
um your your Committee of a Commerce and
Consumer Affairs
did they give any consideration to
some kind of structure that keeps the
cost of
products with a lower THC potency
lower than the more potent
products because you know I think some
some states have a tax system that taxes
at a lower rate for the ones with the
lower THC
or do you think that maybe that just
will kind of come out in the wash it
comes out in the price because of the
the exactly products with the lower THC
you would anticipate would be exactly
okay thank you did you did your
committee talk yes we did we didn't talk
about that because uh um you know again
talking about others say some states
actually cap how much the size of it is
but you know at the end of the day it's
how much your person's buying it so if
you're you're uh if you're they cap it
at five percent milligram five
milligrams and and you sell it at you
sell 20 of them now that's no different
than if you had it at 10 milligrams and
you only sold 10 of them but then the
price obviously it reflects the
differences
representative Army
thank you
um
I'm having a hard time finding a farmer
in this state that is willing to
participate in this I think when you met
when you call them cultivators
cultivators correct you are talking
about
um businesses with greenhouses and
vertical integration absolutely well I
don't know about vertical would you mean
by vertical but that yes they're highly
regulated highly you know and they're
airtight they have their special
ventilation systems I think they'll be
big electric consumers so they might
have to have some net metering there yes
solar installations yes
but on in so we really do have to solve
the vertical integration problem it's
interesting that you bring that up
because Vermont evidently didn't really
think that one through and realized that
there was a delay in being able to have
enough product to sell to Consumers so
we're we absolutely we have the
advantage of seeing what other states
have done and what the problems are so
we are no under No Illusion that that
this is a this is a uh going to give us
deliver money anytime soon because it's
going to take a while uh for them to get
going we have to you know create the
rules uh in terms of what they are you
have to have cities to approve have to
vote to approve to allow these to occur
and how many they want and where do they
want to Zone them where they want them
so cities and towns absolutely have you
know are going to be involved in that
upfront beginning process so so yeah
this is today is a long way away from
when this is really going to be
happening that is true and another thing
that Vermont does follow-up yes thank
you another thing that Vermont does is
to allow and I think encourage outdoor
cultivators they've already had to close
down one
because
you can't control the quality Outdoors
the shrinkage yeah yeah animal shrinkage
or weather shrinkage right now that I I
would say is that I would be very
surprised now we our
in terms of going through other states
you know the you know is probably the
only one that that did that and I'm sure
that that was done in
uh trying to be a little more natural
about the things about the the plants
but in reality you know you're we're
it's this is a controlled
product that we we want to make sure
that that nobody can just stumble onto
it in the woods and say but I'm gonna
steal a butter too
I see a whole bunch of other okay go
ahead so why did you leave in the
um ability to cultivate outdoors I we're
we're pro-choice you know if that if
that's something they want to do but I
can't imagine that her but if you think
that's a bad idea then then I would urge
we'd take that up in the Senate because
that's a policy decision that if you
think we should take that out
yeah representative liebly
thank you thank you for your
presentation this is a lot to process
it's a long Bill nice to see you coming
to walk us through it
um as I'm trying to to understand from
you know the seed to the purpose could
the person consuming I'm thinking about
the process and I'm thinking a lot of
people
probably would be interested in jumping
in at that processor manufacturer
stage like that's a value-added stage
right yes where
um
you can see a lot of profit
being made there my concern is that
it picks up on the representatives
concern about Farmers wanting to do this
and I'm wondering about that's also the
level where we're taxing them so it
seems like that
I see that as being the
the difficult part to get off the ground
and so I'm wondering why
why not put the tax where there's more
interest in participating or more a
lower bar to get into
the market so I'm concerned that putting
all the tax on the farmer is going to
make it even more difficult or less
interesting monetarily for people to get
involved
um I guess the way I saw was that it is
you we certainly allowing for small
operations and that the fees would be
less
for smallers you know obviously the tax
is still the same but that you would
just you know it's it's a cost of doing
business I mean in terms of the that 15
in terms of it is a cost but again we're
we're taxing at the at the most basic
level
you know the product that you're dealing
with so if you think about if they were
going to make you know uh uh the Gummy
Bears or whatever the other products
these you know that there's a lot of
room there for them to uh that to
amortize that 15 you know that tax
whatever it is in terms of that spread
and they won't have to worry about that
that's the key thing they don't have to
worry that or you know if I if I charge
too much for this am I now hurting
myself because of attacks no so at that
point you're going to charge what do you
think is the real market value of the
product
can I have a follow-up
um
so just to continue along that line it
seems like if I were interested in
getting involved in this business
there as a farmer there's no way I
wouldn't continue up the chain because
it seems like it would be
you would have such an interest in in
being at the processor level because
that's where you can really make a
profit
um versus the retail uh no all the way
up yeah okay um you wouldn't want to do
all three right I think that they would
yeah and it just seems like not
it just seems really like that farmer
that cultivator is is just such a high
bar
so that was my concern about are we just
making it that much harder by putting
the tax at that level
I wasn't sure if you no I I would have
to say that my first reaction I was a
little concerned that you know that this
By Doing it The Upfront that way
um but then when I realized that in any
time you know again when we do with the
beer tax where we do we tax it when it
at least it goes from the distributor to
the to the retailer it's up up front in
that 15 days so as long as that you know
the bill is paid on time
then it's not a cash flow problem
that's what that's where I came out you
know have you learned to have that same
15 day Arrangement you know then then no
it's not going to hurt you at all
yeah you're welcome representative
Bolton
thank you down chair um I've got a
question regarding the uh um alternative
treatment centers and the cultivators
that are being engaged to supply them
are they at all perhaps interested or uh
I believe they are I believe they are
and this will certainly allow them to be
able to produce it because I follow
could I ask how many how many
cultivators are there I I believe we
only have what five atcs in the state
okay thank you
okay second round of questions if the
representative will entertain them
representative oh representative
Pillsbury
thank you madam chair
um
thank you chairman hunt
very complicated and I'm just starting
to try to wrap my head around it so
it strikes me that when we make an
analogy to the Beer tax or the way that
we tax fuel at the pump
the taxes applied at the wholesale level
but it's being applied to a finished
product
and it's simply
it's not applied at the retail purchase
point but it's the same product
here it seems to me we're moving in a
different direction
and we're
we're
taxing what is essentially a material
um
before
it's converted into the final product
it's really an ingredient it strikes me
from what I've heard about usually not
familiar but it sounds like a very
significant percentage of the sales
will be processed product as opposed to
a 90 yeah I can't imagine there will be
that many Bud sales get the bag of Bud
the closest to the raw material would be
a reefer
right
um so I'm just I'm not seeing the
analogy to beer I'm stretching for
another analogy with uh how about Timber
attacks gasoline
mm-hmm
and I just came up with that but if you
give me a couple more minutes I'll think
of some more but you guys know all the
taxes you should do better than me
raw material
and I want to consider this but the
analogies that I was going to didn't
seem clear so if I can have a follow-up
question then so you know by the same
token okay Timber tax
still though
there's a huge differential isn't there
in terms of the valuation of the array
of final products and the the amount of
other ingredients that may go into one
form versus another form the amount of
markup the the difference in retail
prices for a variety of different
products
so we're taxing as though it's one
generic ingredient
but we're selling a whole array of
things at different price points
I I'm still trying to figure out if
that's where I think the tax ought to go
right well I would urge you to think in
terms of that if you have a tax you want
to have a tax that is easily
valued in terms of you know what the
what the tax should be easily calculated
and easy to regulate and and enforce
and that that's by taxing at that
cultivator level when they're delivering
it that is uh we're already monitoring
exactly what their production is
we know with their production so we'll
know that the taxes know so it just
makes it so much easier for the state to
apply the tax
when you start adding other value-added
values and stuff like that it makes it
more complicated let alone as I said
shrinkage
um so to me this just seems like a New
Hampshire way of doing it which is to at
the simple basic level easy to enforce
not a lot of you know you know in terms
of we're already going to be going in we
already go right now for instance of the
beer we already visit and look at the
beer manufacturer and what their
production levels are we know what their
what their levels are so when it comes
to the tax there are no surprises
um so in that sense it's simple but I
guess on the other side I'll take from
rivers and reference let's not get
greedy here
you know that's uh let's not try to you
know try to tax it at every level like
other states and that's you know terms
of this is a big Revenue to the state I
mean I don't think we we do we don't
need to do that because it is true
they're going to be their businesses
they're going to pay business profits
tax uh you know bet tax and and uh so
there's a ton of other opportunities uh
you know in creating new employment so
there's plenty of other things for the
state to benefit from
um so we shouldn't you know we should
but but at the end of the day we want to
keep it simple we want how the best tax
that have the least problems in
enforcing
representative what thank you madam
chair
you said earlier some might go beyond
the cultivator level and also
manufacture our retail if they were to
do that what would keep them from
underpricing the cultivation part of it
to avoid the tax make the profit on the
manufacturing and Retail
I mean you're it I don't know which
level
New Hampshire this selling cultivated
product to themselves to manufacture and
then to retail if they were to sell the
marijuana cheaper to some for themselves
essentially to avoid the attacks what's
to keep them from doing that how will we
enforce against it
um so so at the end of the day either
there they have to Value it correctly in
terms of what they would say is the open
market price for it so
um I I don't see that being a problem
thank you very much for your testimony
my pleasure okay I'm sure
representative Malloy
thank you thank you madam chair for uh
and uh thank you for your testimony
today I appreciate it and I have a
pleasure
I've learned a lot here from our
presentation so far is
what I and I understand I think I
understand the the tax structure and how
it's levied and it I conceptually agree
with that
um
the
do I have do I understand that there are
different levels of the active
ingredient in this product and that
regardless of that active the level of
the active ingredient it would still be
taxed at 15 coming from the cultivator
regardless of the strength regardless of
the quality regardless of however these
things are measured that's my question
um there is
the interesting element that uh in every
state has done this is requirements that
uh the product is tested
and they do it for multiple reasons
obviously the most important is safety
is making sure that the product is is
safe and and appropriate
um and we certainly don't want to you
know have uh
I don't know chemicals or whatever DDT
sprayed on top of these plants so that
that is the testing it is a requirement
to know what it is but and more
importantly is that that when it comes
time for them to be selling that product
that cultivator selling that product
that yes they they've got to know what
what they're selling and what they're
you know and pricing it that way
and so there is a invested interest in
making sure they know exactly what
they're selling
you're welcome
okay I don't see him but representative
wilheim are you still here
okay oh it will recognize him if he can
come back and same with representative
Stringham who had to leave but will
recognize them if they come back uh
former Representative Patrick abrami is
here welcome back
thank you man chair and members for the
record
for 12 years and vice chair for six of
those years
and I also the reason I'm here is I also
chaired the marijuana commission back in
17 member Commission
that included legislators as well as
people on both sides of the issue
and we produced a final report and this
is half the report uh was over 200 pages
long
and we had 54 recommendations in there
and I'm happy to say that a lot of those
recommendations are in the bill so I'm
happy about that
I understand I'm here just talk about
revenues I'm Mutual on this I've always
been a no vote so I was wondering why
speaker Jasper at the time selected me
to chair this
um and I my goal was to be fair
in our role in the canister commission
is to come up with the best model for
the state if we were to do this in the
future and at the time there were only
eight states that had legalized and we
talked we spoke to all of those eight
states by via Skype actually because
that was before our current Age
Technology
and we learned a lot
but anyway I I
produced a document four pages
uh I went to the bill
and I have uh some comments
uh some commentary
some future drafting errors that I think
you need to address
uh some strongly suggested
recommendations
and then I gave my version of Revenue
estimates I hadn't seen any real Revenue
estimates so I I went back to the
original report and discussed I took
those numbers and I I brought them
forward to this year and to fit the
model that that came out of Commerce I
did not tell me I did not testify in
Commerce I wanted to let this play
through and it did play through
and what I think I'm going to do is
again the way I set this up I have 14
points I have this document
uh you can follow along with the bill
it's almost uh maybe too detailed but
what I want to do is
start with uh what I just heard you know
most of these businesses are vertically
integrated
so that means the cultivation
the manufacturing and then the retail
okay the three major steps
uh
but but the but they don't have to be
they can be one of any of those okay but
even our our therapeutic uh uh program
medical marijuana by the way there are
four owners and seven that own seven
between them seven locations today and
my understanding is that they're all
vertically integrated
they grow they manufacture and they
retail
but that does not mean that this bill
does not say to a farmer
they can't grow they can bow
next sell to the market
okay they could sell their market look
at anybody else and then it's it's it's
a free enterprise thing so the strong
still survive
um
and in terms of what sold today and
there were more experts on this in the
current days but a current uh facts
about this but people still buy loose
flour they call it and that may be 45 to
50 percent it's kind of and the
manufactured part is is is where you may
create the gumbies and the brownies and
all that stuff
so
but
my understanding of the bill is that a a
cultivator can sell to the manufacturer
or can sell directly to the retailer
and the retailer creates the
um
the bags if you will of
um by ounce or whatever whatever you
decide to buy you want to buy half an
ounce you want to buy a quarter of an
ounce
and announces a lot by the way it sounds
small but in a marijuana world that's
that's a that's a pretty big quantity
that's why it goes by the ounce
so
what I if you if you follow along
some comments
uh on page one line three
there's going to be Revenue going to
education
well that won't happen for a long time I
think 130 years from now
if you look at the unfunded Prince and
liability of
5.69 billion dollars
and I estimate around 43
million best case
that's divide the two numbers
that's 130 years from now so I think
it's a little
I don't think we need to advertise to
the left side because some that may sway
some legislators to vote Yes on this if
they think money's going to education
and education money only kicks in
when we solve the pension liability
problem
when I was first a legislator 12 years
ago that problem was five billion
dollars and was supposed to I heard
always going to get better well now it's
5.6 and 12 years is 5.69 billion so this
will help having the money go there uh
it'll it'll help reduce that number but
I don't think it's it's going to go away
in our our lifetime so education will
never see the money the way the bill is
written education gets the money once we
solve the pension liability problem
on page one line 15 this is in the uh
purpose statement
you get the impression that by doing
this we're going to get rid of the
illicit
Market
we're going to go from illicit Market to
legal to some degree yes
but in every state we talked to and in
my my research even today
that we reduced the illegal Market we
don't get rid of the illegal market so
you may want to edit that out as well uh
this is that has nothing to do with ways
it means but that's just the point
now page 11 line 9
we get to the revenue near the end of
the bill we're going to get there
um
oh the
be talking about the uh these are
yeah the tracking system
uh that's very important
uh the bill does call for it's a May
it's a man not a man it's a shell they
shall have these
businesses shall use the tracking system
and Most states what they do and I think
will happen here is that that the
liquor and cannabis commission will
buy the the software
and then the the various various
businesses will contract with them to to
use the system to track the point is is
that that's a very important feature
because later on I'm going to recommend
other than with with representative hunt
said I think we should be I agree with
100 with the taxing at the cultivation
level
I think we should we should be charging
not on the price but on the but on the
weight on the ounce
but what happens with these tracking
systems you will keep track of the outs
when we transfer
an ounce of the product from the
cultivator to the manufacturer or to the
retailer it keeps track of that we know
where it goes so there's an auditing
mechanism with the tracking system for
following the revenue as well and that's
why I mentioned it here so that that
mechanism will will be in place
I did miss one on pay line four and Page
four and line nine
it talks about
concentrated issue of concentrated came
up
um
yeah it said
concentrated cannabis products what
people don't understand is
some of these products are very potent
stuff
the the concentrates and they create
these waxes
uh that they dab they take the wax to
heat it up it goes from solid to Vapor
and and
and it's 94 THC okay so that's just a
little commentary
uh uh I know that was off that was
anyone yeah let's try to if we can try
to really focus it in other Revenue
stuff that we can actually wait you're
never gonna do that thank you
uh line 12 page 12.
uh line 30 uh line 34.
here's one we we started talking about
and we've heard already about the uh uh
the alternative treatment centers
and the bill is kind of Silent on and it
also has to do with the Dual
this in the build is a provision for
dual use certificates
so that the atcs can also sell retail
so from a ways and means perspective we
have to be able to keep track of because
the atcs are not taxed you're not going
to tax the atcs or are we I don't know
for the product so I think there's
somebody from from the alternative
treatment centers here hopefully that
they will
um address that
uh so that's something that's a that's
silent in the bill I think it needs to
be addressed how do we handle the tax we
want to make sure that when when product
transfers from because we're going to
also allow atcs to sell to the retail
Market
that's fine that should be taxed but if
but these atcs grow so when they sell to
the to the manufacturer to the retail
market for recreational
is that part chat tax so we need to have
a mechanism in the bill to make sure
that uh uh we're only taxing
uh the recreational marijuana that's
being used for a creational
on page 13
this is just a real typo thing
online 26
it goes uh it is it goes a in
parentheses B in parenthesis and it goes
to D in parentheses
I'm assuming it means C in parentheses
or it could be it goes one in
parentheses two and percentage three
percent parentheses I think it should be
it's either D in parentheses or four in
parentheses it's not clear
so that needs to be fixed
um
page 14
line 13.
again representative that is not really
related to the text no but I'm pointing
out to the committee I'm trying to do
your favor to fix the bill
if if you wouldn't mind though focusing
on your your verbal testimony on the
revenue page 14 line 13.
uh
municipality May enact the ordinance
prohibiting
uh that to me this is a an opt-out
Clause I strongly recommend that we put
an opt-in clause
uh and I'll I'll let that one go through
a lottery users opt-in you know we did
opt-in uh to me this is an opt out
clause uh and I'll I'll say it there
I'll leave it at that
page
page uh 21
line uh
line 17 and line 27
there's a reference to RSA 77h
that doesn't it doesn't appear in in
statute
and it and it it does isn't created in
the Bell either so I see representative
Ames is shaking his head yes
uh and I think that reference was there
because of the way it was going to be
taxed before this but that needs to be
fixed and I talked to Keane and Keane is
going to also talk about this so we
don't have to linger on it but uh
also online tournament but uh
line 15.
15.
uh it says money's credited to the fund
shall include deposits into the fund by
the commission pursuing this chapter and
the commission is the when it says
commission and the definitions
commission is the Cannabis alcohol
Commission
and deposits into the fund by the
commissioner of Department of Revenue
pursuant two we're always say blah blah
77h
well my understanding is that the
Department of Revenue has nothing to do
with this anymore
so that's something that needs to be
corrected and uh Keen will will after I
read this I wrote this up I talked to
Keenan and he I think he agrees with
that needs to be fixed
uh line 20 Page 21 line 22.
it references cannabis Commission
by itself there's no such thing as
Canada's condition
when it says it's either commission or
it's the Cannabis and
uh uh
liquor and uh cannabis Commission
all right line 20 page 22 almost there
okay
line one through eight
and this is where I was saying earlier
that we have the unfunded liability this
is this is the section that converts the
money going to
from going to the um
uh pension relief
so this this Clause here from page 22 to
line one through nine or eight
it basically says once we solve the
pension problem
the money will go to education
don't hold your breath
so I
I strongly recommend that this um
and the way I did it I estimated that
revenue is higher than I don't know what
you just got
but I thought net net uh that that uh 80
percent that goes to pension relief that
would then go to education amongst about
43 million you divide the 43 million
into the 5.6 billion
that's 130. it's going to take a long
time to fix that that problem with this
it helps it helps so it's something to
think about as to whether you you want
that
um
then we have page 22 line 11 and 14. by
the way this section is where the money
goes
okay how the money is spent
so line uh 11 to 14
uh
it talks about five percent going to the
municipalities
but only to have a retail store
retail store
I don't like that that's not New
Hampshire
we don't we just don't we don't say well
we're going to reward you
for having a a marijuana store
uh and to me it's a it's a um
we don't do that with any of our other
taxes we don't do it for roomy meals tax
we don't do it with the highway funds
you know you may not have a gas station
near town and and we we still they still
get Highway funds so I think we should
uh make that go to all municipalities I
have a I think that's a great idea I
have a go to municipalities but uh not
in this way plus I also view this as an
enticement to towns
who may not otherwise want to do this
and they're going to say well geez we're
going to get a lot more memorable if we
do this so I don't I don't I don't like
this uh provision that that I just
rewards towns for having a cannabis
business
and then also on the same theme so I I
strongly recommend that we just change
it to all municipalities line 22
uh page 3022 lines 13 to 14 which is a
subset of that
uh then even if you don't change that it
says percentage of tax revenue collected
from retail stores
so again that's an error now because the
retail stores aren't taxing it
get it you understand we tell us our
stories that needs to be modified even
if you don't accept my recommendation to
to make it go to all municipalities then
I don't know how you
how you keep track of this provision
as to someone's gonna have to keep track
of how much I I don't know so that one's
messy
and then line 22
uh excuse me page 22 line 15.
it was the last take if you will
uh five percent not to exceed a million
dollars goes to Public Safety
uh the problem hap what happens is
what happens if what happens if there's
extra money the bill is silent on where
the money where does that money go
does it stay in the fund whatever and
I'll show you in the example that I have
so I I again in terms of the the bigger
issue of to the the commission the
marijuana commission years ago
recommended that it be taxed at the
wholesale level at the grower level okay
so I'm happy to see that
but I I uh I would strongly recommend
that we do it on the outs other than
what representative hunt was saying
uh primarily because it's more stable
let's let's use the two examples that
were mentioned the uh beer tax
and the and the uh rotol which is the
gasoline tax
we tax it up we tax it at the gallon
basis
and that's stable with gas fluctuations
the way they are
it'd be some some periods would have
great revenues other periods would have
bad I think it's more stable better to
tax it at the ounce level at the grower
level
uh now
so so I just want to maybe do on the
text at the ounce level
so Mike I took a crack just to give you
a sense of things what we had come up
with in the marijuana Commission
we had we had talked about taxing and it
announced between 23 and
at the time in the report it was 56 but
I used 57 to run so to be no rounding
uh per ounce
uh time Alaska was was charging fifty
dollars an ounce
at the at the rural level
uh
and and then
we use the New York State methodology
where we estimated there would be 130
cannabis users and about 1563 tourists
we had a tourist Factor
so we we assumed about 131
000 and change users
and the math that they had researched
was that users range from they used five
to seven point nine ounces a year
so I came up with this chart here and
paid my third page of this of the low to
the high of 657 000 ounces to be sold to
a little over a million ounces
and then I use the tax range
of 23 to 57. so at the low end
you're looking at Revenue at 15 million
at the high end you're looking at
Revenue at 59 million
uh and as was said you don't want to tax
it too high
of course you you don't you don't scare
away the the black market very quickly
because but
um
so
so I if I had a pick I would pick
somewhere in the 50 range 50 50 uh you
know that range then the other thing is
the way the math works and this chart
will help answer some questions I think
uh
the the the percentages get applied
after the the cost of running the
program comes off the top
okay we have Revenue the cost goes that
money goes to pay the expense of
regulating it
and then and then it has a bunch of
steps after that so I estimated from the
original bill and I did some adjusting
based on the model in this the midpoint
around 4.4 million to run this whole
thing
so so I took my low and my high worst
case the best case
I subtracted out the midpoint from all
of those to get Revenue after expense 10
000 10 million to 54 million change
then the Bill calls for a hundred
thousand
to go off come off the top of that to go
to Department of Safety
right
so now you're left with what you see
there 10.5 million to 54.6 million
four percent allocation
so 80 goes to the New Hampshire
retirement fund
and that would be best case worst case
84.8.4 million to 43 million
uh then then 10 goes to substance abuse
and you can see the numbers there and
then five percent goes to the
municipalities
and then uh the the rest goes to public
the five percent goes to Public Safety
but with a cap of a million dollars
so you can see in this example
if the revenues were 15 million we'd be
left with no additional money
okay but in the middle and the best case
we're looking at 630 000 and 1.7 million
that doesn't have a home where is it
going to go
so you folks have got to figure out
whether you just want to live alone if
you want to you want to uh make some
recommendations on that
so those are my thoughts
um I have strong recommendations
obviously and there's some some fixing
of the build it needs to happen in terms
of some of the
some of the things that uh that happened
between when the they redrafted the bill
that they things got left in or are
mistakenly still there yes
representative Platt yes your idea of
taxing by the ounce uh honorable abrami
how would you take into account the
difference in quality and strength
between from productivity let's let's
use the example like of gasoline
we have regular
and we have mid-level
we have premium and then we have super
premium and that range could be a dollar
or more between so when we we text
gasoline we don't tax it based on
whether it's premium gasoline or whether
it's regular gasoline same argument is
made here
the same thing with the beer tax as as
representative hunt was saying uh that
right now we're taxing beer at a gallon
basis whether it's
cheap beer or whether it's a premium
beer so I mean and by the way this was
the the conclusion of the commission by
the way not just me then I mean you you
folks can do what you're going to do but
I'm just saying that the commission at
the time said this is what we we should
do
but now that was the logic though behind
it representative Ellery
thank you madam chair and thank you for
the work you did on the uh MRC that I
still have that paperwork yeah
let's go back to page 12 934 we're
talking about the atcs
you're suggesting that the atcs be
treated the same way that a charity that
has a subdivision that is profit making
um that is if they want to grow and they
have an excess from for their own use
within the alternate treatment
that's that excess if it's sold to the
state or to another manufacturer the
excess would be taxed in the same
faction that a a charity that has a
profit operation
would be taxed on its profit operation
only right
see exactly am I getting that correct
the atcs there's no taxing at that at
any level it's in hopefully they'll
they'll testify
uh there's like a fee that they pay for
they they it's under the Department of
Health and Human Services by the way and
they they pay for themselves there's
some kind of a dollar transfer from the
from the atcs to pay for the regulation
of the atcs it's not really a tax but
now if we're going to allow the atcs to
sell their product to retail
some of that product has to be so the
bill is silent how that's going to
happen I mean it can be taken care in
rules
but you know it's up to you folks if you
want to try to fix that is to that part
of the bill that says that the and it
does say
that the atcs now can sell to retail
now there's also another provision in
the bill
that said there's also a pathway
for for them to change their model
that's down the road so I'm not even
going to blur it but that they can
become for-profit
all right
would your suggestion to the atcs to be
to have them set up a separate LLC
within the ATC that would be profit
making so no it doesn't be that
complicated I just think you need to
have you got to make sure that
that the product that they sell to the
retail is and I think through the to the
tracking system the the by the way we
reflection called seed to to sale
the seed to sale system
we'll keep track of how much they're
selling to ATC versus how much is
selling to retail
it's just a matter of I think the bill
is silent on that whole issue of
we have these
Growers that are that are atcs
that are now going to be allowed to sell
to retail
and from a tax position tax
basis
again they have to be able to separate
their crop out if you will as to what's
being taxed and what's not being taxed
that's all I'm saying
follow-up
okay on if we can shift thank you for
discussing that more thoroughly uh if we
could shift gears over to the Department
of Safety there's the allocation of a
hundred thousand and then there's the
five percent and then there's the cap
when you review the bill
do those two add together to reach a
million dollars or is it only the five
percent uh that goes to Public Safety
that has captured a million dollars or
what is your interpretation of well
there's two different public safeties so
Department it's Department the first 100
000 goes to the Department of Safety
State Police
okay the hundred thousand would have
stopped right and that's for keeping
track of statistics on marijuana and
stuff like that it's not prevention it's
not whatever it's more for for
keeping track of of crime rates and
other things
uh related to the Cannabis issue
the the the other when it the the the
the the five percent that goes to the
municipalities down at the bottom there
is that there's two hundred thousands in
this there's a hundred thousand that
comes right off the top
then we're down to municipalities
getting five percent
and that's
all municipalities getting a piece of
that
to to help with uh well back up
the actual oversight of of marijuana is
going to be under the jurisdiction of
uh of liquor enforcement
we already have liquor enforcement and
they work very closely with the with the
town the towns to to regulate alcohol
and tobacco
so their their role is going to be
expanded to include cannabis now
so so this is just some money to help
the towns out
as they help monitor any illegal use of
marijuana
that that second five percent but then
but it caps it at the hundred thousand
not to be confused with the first
hundred thousand that goes to the state
police
this is this is the this is the hunt
this is the up to a hundred thousand
that's going to the municipalities I
didn't write the bill this is why my
interpretation of the bill
okay did that you just
no but thank you representative Doucet
thank you madam chair thank you my good
friend from stratum for his hard work
and testimony this morning I guess my
question just focusing in on the per
ounce proposal that you're making this
this particular commodity isn't
necessarily measured like a gallon of
gasoline a gallon of gasoline is always
a gallon of gasoline we heard testimony
that humidity levels and and dryness of
the product could be different for
instance if I were to take a bushel of
corn and take another bushel of corn a
different strain of corn they may or may
not depending on the the moisture level
way differently so would you wouldn't
you think that would be hard to to
navigate
a per ounce
but I'm the grower when I'm when I'm
selling it to the manufacturer to the
retailer it's something that basis
number of ounces they don't say whether
it's
uh
now there may be different prices based
on the THC level
but to me
that's that's
you know like there are for a regular
gasoline as well as super premium
there's a big wide range just like the
Cannabis there'll be a range of higher
THC products are going to definitely
it cost more
so
follow-up what
and and I totally agree and that price
point will be set but but being a
devil's advocate we're gonna have uh
Regulators that are going to manage this
particular product and if I was
to assume that you know a a regulation
would say that this stuff needed to be
washed prior to and how long in between
the period that this particular product
got a misting and then the time to dry
up I mean it just gets into the minutia
for me
as to how how we weigh this particular
I'm just saying this particular product
to go by weight I don't think they're
going to sell it
moist because I'm just saying it a
gallon is a gallon and it's a standard
this is not a standard measure an ounce
is a standard measure and I totally get
your perspective but I'm curious as to
how the properties of the product itself
there's a real gray area there if you
could appreciate what I'm trying to do
actual marijuana itself behind me but
to me if I was buying it if it was
anything that was was really moist
uh that would really make the price go
up you you put putting your thumb on the
scale here right
so but that's not what they're gonna buy
it should be dried
of flour and that's all part of
Regulation
to me representative Bolton and then we
can go back around okay let's hit
everyone once thank you thank you madam
chair and also pronouncing my name so
eloquently too
um so my question or at least my
observation is very similar to what
representative said
um but I remember well I don't remember
reportedly back in the 60s when you
bought an ounce it was basically
some Leaf some stems some seeds maybe
some flour but now apparently that's
basically what's being harvested at the
um the Growers is just the flower I
believe so I don't think you buy an
ounce of flour
so I I'm kind of confused that if you
start charging per ounce it just may be
just the rough material
and then if you choose to like I don't
see I don't think uh grower sells like
an ounce of flour do you know if that's
the case or I don't know if that's the
case there's all this I'm sure here that
could answer that question so I'm
thinking like a wholesale
um price might be more targeted to like
it doesn't matter what you sell it's 15
of the wholesale price might be more
direct or accommodating to what you're
selling
again that's up to the committee to
decide what they want to do okay
although again there are there are price
fluctuations in marijuana just as they
are in gasoline
depending on what's in the market okay
and
okay so you could start at this level
and all of a sudden you we think we're
getting this amount of Revenue and then
well all the competition that number's
come way down
by doing it on ounce you project
yourself from Place fluctuations and
that's why the commission decided to go
with that that was the Prime reason why
to prevent
any up or down swings in pricing that
would impact the revenue that was our
thinking
representative all me
thank you huh
I like the ounce idea a lot better
that's just a comment on and
the major part of the price that they
get it depends on that they have
prepared it well enough that it will get
a better price and so I don't see that
we've got a problem with that but on the
thing I wanted to ask about is I've got
some stuff from ncsl about marijuana tax
collections in millions from the states
that have been doing this for a longer
time which Maine has not
uh
and I was thinking gee there's a wide
difference here but then I learned that
they all apply other taxes on top of it
is there anything that lists the way we
used to do when we were dealing with the
tobacco tax all the time that lists the
other taxes that the state each state is
putting on these before you get to
business profits and that kind of stuff
right well yeah many states and I was
going to mention this earlier many
states will add a sales tax on top of
the the tax okay but is there so that's
why it's sometimes it's hard to compare
what the tax really is because they're
taxing the tax and they're they're
double taxing it
uh
and there were a few uh you know I've
been outside of this for a while now uh
but it probably is a table
I think the commissioner may maybe have
an answer or some his people may have an
answer now to what they're seeing out
there
but
it's
again we're having a tax
that's it there's no add-on taxes and I
I guess my answer is no I don't I don't
have that chart written for me I don't
have that yeah but I know when we did it
there was a lot a lot of the states and
if you go to the marijuana report you'll
see the eight original states what their
plan was and or they were doing
in terms of of taxing and I think we did
say in addition there was
a sales tax that went on top of it
and that's why you see deflect different
ranges but without so we have to go
somewhere else to get the sales taxes
yeah we have no idea I wish I had a
point I don't
I just passed out a revised Revenue
estimate hopefully you guys will get a
chance to look at that it doesn't have
revenues oh it doesn't have revenues oh
I haven't looked at it okay great okay
any final questions for the
representative former representative so
I'm glad I gave you at least my version
of what they're here sir thank you very
much for doing the very next day I
thought it was helpful to show how the
money flows by that last chart to say it
this much goes to this this and this in
that order
no thank you so much all right thank you
so right now I don't see any other uh
Representatives or senators in the room
so I just I'm going to go in the order
that I received the pink cards next up
would be Ross Connolly
foreign
thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Ross Connolly I'm the deputy state
director for Americans for Prosperity in
New Hampshire here to voice our support
for HB 639 and uh provide a little uh
context on on some of the the tax of of
evolving on this bill and uh maybe a
couple suggestions
um so as the committee is very well
aware uh New Hampshire's an island of
prohibition surrounded by states that
have legalized in in one way or another
uh and a lot of the Coalition that that
came together to support this bill of
which uh AFP was a member
um really looked at the lessons taken
from a lot of these states that surround
us
um currently we're uh exporting all of
our decision making to neighboring
states uh state governments on how a
retail cannabis Market should be
regulated without getting any of the
benefits from that legal Market uh this
would shift the power back to the
Granite State uh by by putting the
decision-making power in your hands and
in the hands of the The Liquor
Commission
um
this legislation currently as has been
discussed has a 15 cultivator wholesale
tax uh and much of the funds would go
towards paying off some of our biggest
Financial issues including uh the
unfunded pension liability and
eventually property taxes
um although both both would would go
towards reducing property taxes
um
the original version of this bill uh had
a a
extended the meals and rooms tax of 8.5
percent uh for a retail uh at point of
sale tax
um
for for the only only tax uh the the
committee shifted that but I'll just uh
go through why the the commission the
the Coalition supported uh and put that
in in the original bill so first uh it's
an existing tax uh so we're not creating
any new taxes uh with the meals and
rooms tax second it's easy to implement
uh since it would be based on the price
of product at point of sale uh and
lastly 8.5 percent would put New
Hampshire in an extremely competitive
position uh with with our neighboring
states it would be uh likely the lowest
tax rate in the country on cannabis
um as I mentioned and and as we've been
discussing the house Commerce Committee
shifted that tax uh to to a wholesale uh
paid by uh cannabis plant cultivators uh
we're not opposed we're not taking any
position one way or the other whether
it's uh retail or or uh wholesale
however we do suggest that the the
committee ensure the tax is easily
implemented in a way that shifts with
market prices so when the price price of
the product inevitably drops uh we're
not uh having a prohibitive tax rate
this has been an issue I think the
previous uh speaker mentioned uh Alaska
where they have a a dollar amount fixed
price on on a weight of a product I
would highly highly recommend not doing
that Most states are trying to undo that
uh since the price drops uh so much that
the tax could be 50 of the price of the
product
um the the end goal uh for all of us is
is to reduce black market influence so
keeping that tax rate low uh and able to
fluctuate with the price of the product
is is the best way to go in in our mind
um
I I'd be happy the one other sort of
fiscal item I mentioned you know uh the
really the the takeaway from every state
that is legalized is to keep the
regulations and barriers to entry into
the industry low uh keep those fees low
uh for for licenses and to keep the
taxes as as low as possible
um and I do have uh that chart that that
was being mentioned I I if if any of the
members have questions on what the tax
rate is in any of the northeast states I
do have those those numbers with me so
I'd be happy to take any questions but
uh you know our our overall message that
is that we're in support of this bill
and uh we encourage the committee to
work through the process and and uh pass
the bill as written
could you send us that
schedule or absolutely uh I can just you
know just quickly Most states have
compounding taxes so they'll they'll
establish a cannabis retail tax
sometimes a cannabis wholesale tax on
top of their uh I I know that in New
Hampshire we don't really know what this
is but uh on top of their existing sales
taxes in those States uh so it's a
compounding uh tax system uh in almost
every every state in the region where
you have multiple sales taxes usually
local excise taxes on top of uh on top
of existing taxes
if you have a chart that you could email
the committee that would be helpful
absolutely are you open to questions yes
any questions on this side of the room
questions on this side representative
Bolton uh thank you madam chair so I'm
actually looking at the document that
you're you're referring to and my
concern about an ounce of what so I
guess Alaska
does have a variety of different charges
per ounce one is um fifty dollars per
ounce for flowers mature buds 25 per
ounce for immature or abnormal buds
fifteen dollars per ounce for trim any
clones whatever that is it's a buck per
clone
um is that
a preferable way to go do you think or
uh thank you for the question
representative I I would say no
um because again
when you establish a new industry
especially in this area we've seen a
Massachusetts Main Vermont what have you
the the price is usually High to begin
with so it could be three hundred
dollars per ounce you have a 50 tax on
on that uh on that ounce but when the
price begins to drop that 50 dollars
becomes a massive portion of of what
these uh cultivators are looking at
paying which might which would likely
result in in the price of the product
not dropping and and being competitive
to knock out the black market uh so so
we support the idea of doing a percent
base base tax you know we think the 15
might be a little high uh I would uh
recommend the committee look into the
existing tax on Vapes which is eight
percent
um uh as a little more uh a lower tax on
those cultivators but again uh we're not
taking a direct position on on uh tax
rate
thank you very much thank you very much
okay the chair will recognize
Elizabeth's Sergeant on behalf of New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Elizabeth Sargent
here today
um representing the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police in
opposition to the bill
um I was not prepared to testify I do
have Chief provensky's testimony he's
president of the association and I would
just note
um and he should try to address the cost
and I would note that we would agree
with the fiscal note in the bill that
there will be increased law enforcement
costs increased by highway safety cost
and increased addiction cost so
um with that I'd be happy to take any
questions back to the association but
probably don't feel comfortable
answering the cost questions
representative only
do we have a copy of this demo oh you're
yes you're going to distribute it yes
yes I'll have some reading to do tonight
yeah go ahead and hand that out okay and
uh if we have questions we know how to
reach you I think uh that your is your
contact information on there
um no but I'll send it to the committee
we'd be happy to answer any questions
okay great thank you thank you so much
okay the let's see I have the d-array
here do you want to do that now or do we
wait till a little bit later what are
you thinking
let's let's hold off and do some other
folks just so we can ask them all the
technical questions I have Nathaniel
I'm gonna
g New Hampshire cannabis party
I I don't know how to pronounce his last
name I'm going to ask him to do it say
that again Gurion Gurion thank you
um Madam chair might ask him to spell
his name again oh I'm sorry no it's not
right there I can't read that oh we
can't read this g u r
thank you thank you
chair I have uh some reference material
um
absolutely
foreign
chair members of the committee
um thank you for the opportunity to
share a couple of my perspectives on
this bill and revenue issues my name is
Nathaniel Gurion
um I'm glad we got the spelling worked
out
um I um
CEO of a company that for about eight
years has been providing Financial
Services banking payments compliance
help to the industry I am also the
executive director of the New Hampshire
cannabis party
and I write a
bi-monthly column for the Conway Daily
Sun
covering the New Hampshire cannabis
industry
um
the first thing that it's important to
talk about I think is that the Cannabis
industry is evolving it's very complex
um it requires skill sets and experience
that
um you know are unusual I think that's
one of the reasons why the Liquor
Commission did not have a lot of
enthusiasm for running this entire
industry in the state however
um because it's complicated
um
I think that
it's very important
to stay away from any additional
unnecessary complication and talking
about
trying to set up a revenue or tax
structure that is based on
the eccentricities and individual nature
of cannabis products such as flour or
finished products or potency or weight
is going to be a nightmare I think in
terms of supervision in terms of having
inspectors to take a look at this the
entire regulatory regimen in order to
try to monitor this adequately is going
to be expensive mistake ridden and it's
going to create a lot of complex
conflicts
and on the other hand
representative hunt came up with what I
thought was a very elegant and Brilliant
and simple suggestion
and that is simply to put a percentage
tax on cultivators and the reason for
that and the the
inspiration of that is that that that
creates basically one toll booth for the
entire industry no product is going to
get into the market with one exception
that I'll get to without being produced
by a cultivator or a farmer so that
means if you set up one toll booth and
tax it okay every other part of the
Cannabis economy Downstream will have
paid their taxes without having to
burden them with filing reports with
um
uh with having to get inspected and so
on and if we do not look at the product
itself in terms of potency or weight or
type of product but all we have to do is
track the revenue of the cultivators on
a monthly basis at a percentage we have
an incredibly simple non-invasive uh tax
structure that also covers the entire
economy
um
and
it's just vastly simpler and we're not
going to get into any trouble with that
um the um you know thing that to keep in
mind also is that at the cultivation
level the quality of the product the
potency of the product whether it's an
outdoor grow or an indoor grow is going
to affect the price that they're able to
sell it for and so the tax rate will
automatically adjust based on the
quality of the product the type of
product and so on simply because that's
there's a market price for different
types of products in fact this um
perhaps deliberately or accidentally
also tends to provide a little subsidy
for outdoor Farmers because typically
outdoor grown product sells for Less in
the marketplace and so their tax rate
will be lower the guys who are building
greenhouses have specialized products
that often uh you know they're much more
controllable they may have higher
potencies they may have more specialized
uses and as a result they're going to
command a higher price and they'll pay a
higher tax
um so I am very much in favor of the um
tax structure that came out of Commerce
Committee
um and um would really really caution
you guys not to uh and pun intended get
into the weeds with this uh you know uh
you don't you don't need to I mean if
interested but but really you don't need
to we can accomplish our purpose in a
very simple Manner and just track the
revenue either on a tax return or bank
statements um or whatever from the
cultivators
um however and this is what I passed out
some of this material on
um
one thing that
is coming is interstate commerce now
um the state of New Hampshire can either
recognize that and embrace that and have
a
um an industry and a regulatory
framework that Embraces that and
encourages that and builds our state's
prosperity in this industry
um recognizing that that's coming or we
can have it imposed upon us as you'll
see from the material I've passed around
it's inevitable
um and uh you know the federal courts
are going to invalidate state residency
requirements
largely as a result of that and they are
going to invalidate States
practicing having kind of a insulated
bubble economy that's what has evolved
in the industry at this particular point
but those barriers are soon to break
down and we need to be aware of that and
the reason why that's important on a
revenue basis is because not if but when
product is imported from other states
if we are only taxing our local domestic
um cultivators then we are going to put
them all at a huge disadvantage over
product that gets imported in
so by simply amending the current
um
uh proposal to say that tax is on
cultivators and importers
we have now actually covered the entire
market so if you're growing it or
producing it here in New Hampshire
you're going to pay that tax it'll go
Downstream 15 percent is not as scary a
number as it seems because it's at a
wholesale price so that's really kind of
where the the that kind of like the
bottom of the pricing obviously as it
moves up towards manufacturing and
retailing the cost of the product is
higher and so the effective tax because
it was taxed at the wholesale level was
lower
I think that it's um that it's very
compelling that instead of having a 10
tax on cultivation and then five percent
on retail that we do 15 right at that
right at that one toll booth level
um and um and then we're able to
advertise and uh you know our retailers
dispensaries delivery services and so on
will be able to say that you can come to
New Hampshire and buy cannabis tax-free
there's no extra tax on it at all and
we're covering it now five the the extra
five percent on a cultivation level
obviously is worth less than five
percent on a retail level but
nonetheless it would it would give us a
compelling advantage and would give
um our business operators a compelling
Advantage
um the other thing to also keep in mind
um and um uh the representative uh here
uh who's
can't actually read your name but um
alluded to it
um is that um in addition to the core
industry cultivators dispensaries
manufacturers test Labs uh people who
are actually involved in the the prime
cannabis activity
um I'm sure you're all well aware that
there are many many support industries
that uh that help this industry there's
Hospitality there's greenhouses there's
equipment there's Transportation there's
legal and accounting services a whole
the whole economy gets boosted by that
as well as the core industry and as they
grow and flourish and start generating
profits
um
generally speaking unless the tax burden
like it is in California is crazy and
excessive
um the the mere elevation and increase
in overall business activity and
prosperity is likely to generate lots
more revenue for our standard business
taxes than it would even generate just
on the on the core cannabis taxes so I
think having a a modest tax of 15 at the
cultivation and importation level would
basically cover that in addition keep in
mind that products that get imported
into the state may not be simply flower
that would be generated by the
cultivators but it could be gummy bears
it could be finished products it could
be and so of course if they come into
the state as finished products they're
also going to get taxed at a higher rate
because you know they're more of a
value-added product
um
so anyway those those are kind of the
main points
um the um
I think it's also important um simply to
mention
um that um the Cannabis industry as it's
currently constructed
um and uh for a lot of reasons because
of the tension between Federal
illegality and state legality there's a
tremendous amount of supervision and
compliance that goes part and parcel
with the Cannabis industry right now so
not only at the cultivation level but at
all levels retail manufacturing there's
very close monitoring of inventory and
pricing and point-of-sale proceeds and
making sure that the operators stay on
the straight and narrow and that's not
just on the cultivation level retailers
are required to have their inventory
tracked by the state and by the Banks
and by their financial service providers
their point of sale systems are tracked
and so uh
it's very easy to tell whether they're
straying out of their Lane and that's at
all different levels of the industry
um so and the only other thing I'll
mention is that um you know I do have
a certain amount of knowledge and
understanding on the Banking and
Financial Services and payments issues
so if they relate to anything that
you're looking at at this moment we'll
be happy to answer any questions
representative Phillips thank you madam
chair I want to thank you for pointing
out that
your assumption that we will eventually
just have interstate commerce because I
think you're right in it I hadn't been
thinking along those lines
um what I don't understand though is if
if we assume that that's going to happen
I don't understand while you why you are
still suggesting taxing it at the
wholesale level
and then saying that gummies will be
taxed when they are transported into
this state
because I think that sounds very
complicated it seems to me that if we're
going to have interstate commerce we
should just have a have a tax at the
retail level so can you tell me why
that's not the best solution well you
have to Yes um you have to keep in mind
that there's a lot of channels of
distribution here
um gummy bears could come in to the
state and maybe some of them will get
retailed some of them may get wholesaled
some of them may get re-exported out to
other states they may ultimately get
into International you know
International Commerce
and if we do not have a mechanism to
basically
tax everything as simply as possible and
without again looking at the
um
particularly you know the individual
characteristics of the product but
everything that basically is either
produced in a state or there's Commerce
in the state that the simplest way to
Simply impose a uh you know basic and
modest tax on that I think would be the
best uh you know and so you know
especially as distribution begins to
open up and is is less controlled within
the state
um you know we don't want to have a lot
of these large loopholes that uh you
know clever operators are going to find
a way through so if we have if we kind
of establish as I said one toll booth
okay that everybody has to go through
and then at that point in time they can
freely trade and the tax has been paid
and we don't have to track that anymore
I think that would be the simplest way
to do it
representative ulery and then
representative almi
thank you madam chair uh in your review
of this bill
um
the base tax the toll booth as you talk
on is that based on net revenue or gross
revenue in your understanding of the
bill
oh that would certainly be gross revenue
so business taxes and our business
expenses and such would not be
deductible from the gross revenue
generated well I don't think it's
contemplated to be an income tax uh you
know it's a it's essentially a sales tax
so whatever you sell the product for you
pay the tax on that on that basis
all right thank you representative homie
thank you thank you how do you propose
that we figure out what's been imported
once
once Commerce is made free and easy
across all of our borders which
essentially it is now but not legally
um
I haven't thought that mechanism through
be perfectly honest I think that that's
certainly something that uh would not be
uh you know super difficult to design
something like that but to be perfectly
honest I didn't I mean I I think it's
it's perfectly doable but I don't have a
mechanism that I have thought through on
that
questions on the other side of the room
in the committee no any other follow-ups
representative alright
to discuss your Interstate Karma right
now it's illegal interstate commerce was
regulated by the federal government uh
that's something we don't have to worry
about at this point uh until they figure
out the tax and legality issue at the
federal level
we don't have to worry about it is there
a question representing illegal don't
you agree with me
there you go
I'm glad you got around to a question uh
no it's actually not illegal the
interesting thing is um there is an
assumption I mean of course
um
any involvement in aiding and abetting
narcotics trafficking uh
according to federal law is illegal
arguably if we have a conversation about
possibly uh uh cannabis Commerce we're
breaking federal law
however the feds have a not weighed in
on interstate commerce of cannabis they
don't have an actual prohibition they
have the right to regulate it within a
narrowly confined framework which is
discussed in the material that I gave
you but at this particular moment and
this has actually been the holding of
several courts some of the material
which is in the things that I sent out
to you it is not currently illegal to
engage in interstate commerce the reason
why interstate commerce is prohibited is
because every state has prohibited it in
their own enabling law
it's it's actually
you know for you know I having been
involved in banking and and payments for
a very long time
um there's a misnomer that there is a
restriction on the federal level as
regards Banking and credit cards and all
the rest of that that's actually not
true the entire restriction emanates
from
um the individual Banks and the credit
card companies who choose not to do
business in this industry but actually
all of this is uh you know it's not
federally legal but it's federally
permitted
representative horse thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question so you mentioned earlier in
your testimony about the current New
Hampshire cannabis industry what is the
New Hampshire cannabis industry I mean
are we talking I don't know I have no
idea so I mean are do we do we sell
brownies and gummy bears or you know
give out free pizza or what do we do uh
well um if you mean um from in the
context of my um covering the New
Hampshire cannabis industry uh in um in
my column uh it would be really
developments in the New Hampshire
cannabis industry right now the New
Hampshire cannabis industry consists of
a few
atcs which are vertically integrated
that grow their own product and produce
their own product and I guess that's our
cannabis industry um but in the scope of
what I'm writing about uh you know all
of what we're doing here is kind of part
of the Cannabis industry per se
follow-up
so is it legal to grow cannabis in New
Hampshire and
sell it or give it away or what well my
understanding is that it's legal if you
have an ATC license to grow it for the
purpose of providing product to your
business is that medical use yes yeah
okay thank you madam chair
representative putt
thanks for taking my question you say
several several all states or several
States block Imports so it's going to be
State grown doesn't it fly right in the
face of the U.S Commerce Clause
um
well actually
um the answer to your question is
um very thoroughly answered by the
material that I passed out but
essentially
um
the the strong argument that it looks
like uh the court the courts are already
deciding in this way and it looks like
they're all pretty much going to fall in
line with this is that based on the
dormant Commerce Clause
um that um in point of fact the states
have no right to prohibit Interstate uh
Commerce and are doing so
um for a variety of reasons which are
addressed in the material I gave you but
um from what I recall
um One is because they think that the
feds might be prohibiting it and they're
anticipating that or they're looking to
perhaps lessen the tension between
federal and state law number two
um they are you know likely motivated to
try to protect their local nascent
um and uh you know just developing
cannabis industry from Interstate
competition but that actually happens to
be in direct contradiction to the inter
State the Commerce laws
representative alming
thank you when I was a student
which is a very long time ago I remember
on learning that the reason we had no
research on the effects of cannabis was
that the U.S department of Agriculture
would not allow anyone to grow cannabis
on
on in research
you're telling me that all of this is a
mirage
I'm sorry um what's a mirage that
that the federal government has a
Prohibition against the
the
ice
growth and and on
use of cannabis
well yeah the um
uh classifies it as a schedule one
narcotic with no benefit
um and um state law individual state
laws contradict that directly
um and the um the federal law um still
prevails and you're absolutely right
about the research uh it was actually
prohibited by the DEA
um who apparently had issued one license
to one Southern University to grow some
crops for research um but certainly the
research has been severely constrained
by the federal prohibition and and it it
remains federally illegal today uh
absolutely uh you know there have been
um there there was a um starting in 2014
there was a amendment that was attached
to the federal budget which is renewed
every year so far since then which
prohibits the Department of Justice from
Prosecuting anyone one involved in a um
you know properly constituted state
legal program but that does not relieve
um
anyone from the fact that that all of
these all of these cannabis businesses
and the entire industry and all the
state sanctioned operations are in
violation of federal law
um you know likewise on the the banking
side
um uh the Department of Treasury through
their fincen uh uh federal financial
crimes uh enforcement division that
regulates Banks and compliance and all
the rest of that
um issued a memo in 2014 that
specifically provided guidelines for
banks and financial service providers to
um they describe it as meet their
anti-money laundering and other
compliance requirements
by following guidelines that they had
outlined for doing that but they
specifically also said in that memo that
the memo does not therefore legalize it
in any particular way nor does it affect
the fact that that even though the bank
might be in in compliance with their
examination standards and might be able
to therefore Bank people in the industry
that nonetheless that doesn't relieve
the fact that all of such activity is is
being done in violation of federal law
okay I'm gonna thank you very much for
all your knowledge and testimony and
just remind the committee that we are
focused on the revenue if you are
certainly welcome to do any of the
research on the background we're meeting
some great experts in the field but
let's try to keep this focused on the
revenue thank you so much
okay and I will let everyone know
because I can see people squirming a
little bit we are going to do a hard
stop at noon
so that my committee members can have a
lunch break
um so we're going to try to get through
the rest of the pink cards so if
everyone could just be a little bit
concise in your remarks that would be
helpful or we will have to uh recess the
the hearing and start it over next week
or two weeks from now okay
representative Jim no excuse me uh Jim R
representing himself from Hillsboro I
cannot read your last name if you could
come up
thank you
all right we'll have to meet in two
weeks welcome thank you thank you madam
chair members of the committee my name
is Jim Riddle r-i-d-d-l-e
from Hillsboro and I'm here to support
uh House Bill 639
and I'd like to let you know that I have
a USDA hemp producer license
brought it with me here
officially
granted by USDA for growing hemp
under the terms of my license
I'm required to destroy or remediate any
plant materials that contain more than
0.3 percent THC
so I can grow those plants but every lot
has to be individually sampled tested if
it's hot if it's above 0.3 then there
needs to be either composting burying
burning or remediation which means
mixing with some other product
to bring that level down
now my own interest business interest is
in producing seeds so I don't mind
destroying composting I love to make
compost anyway so I don't mind turning
that into compost but it is a
potentially marketable product if this
bill is passed and signed into law
and I do stand ready to invest in the
Cannabis side here in New Hampshire if
it indeed is signed into law but I
cannot do that right now I can only
focus on the seed and speaking of seeds
uh I urge you to make one small change
uh to this bill in in the definition of
cannabis
it lists seeds under the definition of
cannabis and if you're not aware the DEA
The Drug Enforcement Administration has
officially ruled that cannabis seeds are
hemp
because they contain less than 0.3
percent THC
and uh the I have copies of the dea's
determination letter with me and it says
specifically marijuana seeds that seed
that has a Delta 9 THC concentration of
not more than
0.3 percent on a dry weight basis meets
the definition of hemp and is not
controlled under the Controlled
Substances Act
um and all seed
hemp seed cannabis seed whatever you
want to call it is below 0.3 percent THC
so I do encourage you to amend uh the
bill because it really affects what
would be taxed
um and it uh
where'd my copy of the bill
I don't think I need to read through the
exact language but under the definition
of cannabis any of the inclusion of
seeds in that definition should be
deleted
seed seeds thereof
and to add the word seeds
uh in the sentence that says cannabis
shall not include hemp and then it
should say seeds fiber produced from the
stock soil cake Etc
so uh
that's the one
substantive change otherwise
as a potential cultivator
15 seems high
seems like it could generate a lot of
money for the state and you said you
didn't want it to be an income generator
I would think something in the range of
half of that would be reasonable
seven and a half eight percent at most
ten percent
this
could give Farmers entrepreneurs a lot
of opportunity here in New Hampshire to
participate in a growing market right
now as you know people are going to
Maine they're going to Massachusetts New
York Vermont
Etc we're losing money from our state we
can capture that and help support
Growers here and I really encourage
keeping the outdoor cultivation language
it's not for the state to micromanage
how a farmer conducts their business
whether it's in a greenhouse whether
it's hydroponic or whether it's outdoors
and being done biodynamically that's up
to the grower not the state to make that
choice and I did have one suggestion uh
also uh to for you to consider on page
22 the discussion of that five percent
uh of the income going to municipalities
and then
there is objection or concerns about
with a retail store but I would suggest
that be changed to a cannabis
cultivation facility
so if municipality has an operational
cannabis cultivation facility they would
qualify because these are the entities
you're asking to pay the tax the
cultivation facilities it would make
sense that the revenue generated a
portion of that comes back to those
municipalities where those cultivation
facilities are located
thank you I'd be happy to take any
questions
what about me
thank you
yeah I have not been able to find
out what's willing to get involved in
this program because they think they'll
be taken over by the conglomerates
uh and because it costs a great deal to
do indoors on Outdoors
on in other states I believe that they
are doing a considerable amount of of
inspections and
requirements of how you grow it since it
is going to be used internally
do you
have an idea of how many people might be
willing to try to Do It Outdoors because
that's going to increase our costs
I have no idea how many people in New
Hampshire might be interested in doing
it Outdoors thank you and Madam chair
and representative
um
I do think for the smaller grower which
would be what my interest is totally
um
having that outdoor option certainly can
help keep cut costs down I think having
the different tiers for the for the
registration fees is totally uh
appropriate and just so you know under
the hemp program I have to track all of
my grows everything has to be sampled
and I have to file annual reports with
the Farm Service Agency that is part of
electronic database tracking all of my
movements as a hemp producer and I don't
know if the people studying this have
looked at the existing USDA hemp program
as a model for tracking production but I
think it's it's accessible to any grower
regardless of your scale
thank you very much thank you very much
the chair will recognize
you're from New Hampshire futures
is it Kate I'm sorry it's Kate that's
fine hater Katie it's fine uh thank you
all very much I will be very brief I do
have written testimony for the committee
uh my name is Kate fry I'm the vice
president of advocacy at new Futures new
Futures works on health and wellness
policies
um uh with stakeholders prevention
Partners to prevent and reduce alcohol
and drug problems in our state
um we realize that it is imperative to
get cannabis commercialization policy
right from the start
um so optimal policy has to include uh
best available scientific evidence and
reduce public harm so we have developed
um principles that I will uh hand out to
you in our testimony the principle
however that is most aligned to the work
today are the ways and means committee
is ensuring appropriate funding for
cannabis Revenue to be directed to
reduce harms so we look at policy in
bills that apply revenue for substance
misuse education prevention and
treatment and recovery and also creating
mass media and social media campaigns
and the potential harms before the law
is effective that's something we heard
time and time again on the Cannabis
commission that I also served on so I
will hand out to you a side by side of
our principal with what's in the bill we
are happy to see there there is a
substance abuse Abuse Prevention and
Recovery Fund
um which funds shall be deposited into I
think they are
um saying 10 percent of revenues however
I guess I am concerned of how much that
will really be based on the expenses
um outlined in the bill by The Liquor
Commission also
um not having a great grasp on what the
revenue will bring forward however there
is not anything in the bill that creates
a mass
um media campaign prior to the bill
being effective we understand the
department is uh has an amendment to use
revenue from the Dual light use license
bill
um portion of the bill in this in this
bill we would support that amendment in
order to give the revenue to the
department to create the mass media
campaign but again I don't think there's
anything in there that would have it
from the start and that's really
important so before the law is effective
we really have to have these policies in
place so overall because it does not
meet all of the principles we are still
opposed to hb639 but we are happy to
work with the committee on language and
one thing that I will bring uh send to
the committee is a recent report from
the urban Institute on tax policies that
give you the pros and cons of all tax
policies and a couple Representatives
brought up earlier about looking at the
potency
three taxes have moved in that direction
of having a higher potency tax for
higher potency product it's a way to
reduce the use of high potency products
which of course we are concerned about
with the impact to kids but also if
producers want to do that they can be
taxed at a higher rate so I will send
this committee reports that report that
might be helpful
thank you would you be open to questions
yes questions from the committee
thank you very much
okay the chair I'm going to bring up the
agency's last because we might end up
with a work session on this and we'll
probably have you come back for those
um Matt Simon from primeatc are you here
there you are
foreign
thank you madam chair
honorable committee members good to see
you again
for the record my name is Matt Simon I
live in Nashua I work for Prime ATC
we're one of the three companies that's
licensed to provide therapeutic cannabis
to patients in New Hampshire
there are currently about 14 000
patients who are registered with the
therapeutic cannabis program
we operate two dispensaries one in
Merrimack one in Chichester we have a
cultivation and production facility in
Peterborough we are a non-profit and we
have about 55 employees
so I was in the process last Friday of
preparing written testimony and I saw my
former colleague Karen O'Keefe from the
marijuana policy project sent you about
eight pages of detailed written
testimony much of which was exactly what
I was going to write so I got lazy I'm
going to defer and agree with much of
what my former colleague I worked at the
marijuana policy project for 10 years
and I agree with
her perspectives generally
um
so first of all we do support the bill
although with somewhat less enthusiasm
than before it was amended by the
Commerce Committee I was a member of the
Coalition that drafted the original bill
which I believe was based on best
practices observed from neighboring from
other States including neighboring
states based on Lessons Learned learned
and
that's still true of much of the bill
maybe not all of it so I'm
some of the things we're disappointed in
are outside the scope of this committee
home cultivation annulment Provisions so
I won't elaborate on those focus on the
things that you are concerned about
primarily the tax structure so we've
already had a lot of talk about the
proposed 15 percent cultivation tax I'm
not an expert on tax policy I would be
willing to go along with this if
somebody could explain it to me in a way
that makes sense that it's actually
workable particularly for the atcs and
for other vertically integrated
businesses
so if we had a three-tier model it would
make sense there would be a transaction
every time a cultivator sells to a
manufacturer or a retailer and you just
take 15 percent of that price that's
easy well we're a vertically integrated
business we would we be selling cannabis
to ourselves and if so at what price
would be be selling cannabis to
ourselves if we could we would sell
cannabis we would it seems like we'd be
incentivized to sell it to ourselves at
a penny a pound if if we were allowed so
we'd have to come up with some kind of
average and that's problematic in every
way that I can think of uh first of all
there's no legal Market in no New
Hampshire so there wouldn't be
transactions to base it on we'd have to
look at other states if you look at
prices in other states they vary
dramatically
in the early phase of these markets
before they mature prices are extremely
high and then there is an inevitable
point where the oversaturation point is
reached where Supply catches up with
demand and that's what's happening in
Massachusetts right now the price of
adult use cannabis in Massachusetts has
reduced by more than half in the last
year
so 15 of whatever it was a year ago
would be half of that today by
Massachusetts prices even if once we do
have pricing that's predictable and
established uh that doesn't solve the
tremendous variability that exists
between a pound of cannabis a versus a
pound of cannabis B it is an
Agricultural Product freshness is
incredibly important uh how well it has
been trimmed and harvested and shucked
and cured there are all sorts of
shortcuts you can take in the
cultivation process that result in a
worse product so buyers are very
interested in quality they want to
inspect it and make sure that it will
this be able to sell at my retail store
or will I be able to use this as a
manufacturer so we keep coming back to
15 percent of what being being the
question and I would love to understand
how that that might work but I don't yet
um
the interstate commerce issue is also
very sticky and that's already been
touched on I agree with Mr Gurion that
it's very likely
not that Congress will do anything
because Congress is Congress but that
courts a court will at some point uh
rule as as indicated and strike down
interstate commerce uh restrictions on
the basis of the dormant Commerce Clause
when that happens yes one option would
be to extend the cultivation tax to to
importers
I do think it's an issue that needs to
be addressed in this legislation rather
than waiting down the road because if if
a court rules and say
March of next year that
interstate commerce is is no longer
restricted uh the legislature doesn't
reconvene until January you have to pass
a bill through the through the whole
process so if we have anticipated this
in advance so that it doesn't require
cannabis businesses in New Hampshire to
wait eight months a year or more for the
legislature to catch up and react to
whatever the feds has done that would be
wonderful
um incidentally a retail tax really does
that because if you're just taking eight
percent or whatever percent of the
retail transactions then that insulates
you against
whatever might happen really anywhere uh
anywhere else
so one of the issues that didn't come up
with that if you're a Manufacturing
licensee in New Hampshire
uh having the Cannabis you import or
purchase to make edibles or whatever out
of uh having that be subject to a 15 tax
would be prohibitive uh consider that
these businesses in other states don't
face that restriction if you make
edibles in Vermont you don't have to pay
a 15 tax on the Cannabis you buy to make
edibles out of
same in Massachusetts same well not in
Maine actually Maine has a really
complicated tax system as you've heard
that you I would recommend you not adopt
so I agree it should be very simple
and if it could be very simple one-time
tax at the cultivation level that'd be
great
the really simple tax that make sense to
me is applying it to every retail
transaction and the other way that makes
it really easy is for therapeutic
cannabis program everybody has agreed
throughout this process that therapeutic
cannabis should remain untaxed in New
Hampshire
that's really easy if
somebody presents their card they're a
patient they they buy from you know
there would be for the dispensaries they
would have dual use so one cash register
would be entirely therapeutic products
that would be untaxed the bill also
envisions adult use retailers that are
not atcs down the road being able to get
what's called a therapeutic cannabis
endorsement and if we didn't do that we
would not be expanding access to
patients patients would only have seven
places to buy cannabis in the state and
we might have lots of adult use
retailers so from a policy perspective I
think it's important to increase
patient access
but I'm not sure
how an adult use business could exempt
patients from taxation I see how an ATC
could do it theoretically we would
separate the Cannabis we grow into two
streams one would get coded as
therapeutic and go into that system one
would get coded as adult use go into
that system we would charge ourselves 15
percent of whatever mythical number
comes up on the adult use side uh and
not charge it on the other side but for
an adult use retailer is envisioned by
this bill I don't have any clue how they
could possibly be how patients could be
Exempted from Taxation and I think it's
very important that patients be Exempted
for taxation for policy reasons that are
outside the purview of this committee
but pretty important I think
final point the bill envisions dual use
conversion fees for the atcs that's
something we went along with it'd be
about 100 up to a I think it's a hundred
thousand dollars for each
location that would be transitioning to
dual use it's a lot of money
we were on board with that because the
original bill is drafted created a
cannabis Business Development Fund and a
Justice reinvestment fund usually part
of this conversation uh is understanding
that we've had 70 plus years of
Prohibition the countless lives and
families have been ripped apart and
people have been economically devastated
in addition to having a freedom taken
away and there's usually some attempt to
make sure that small businesses
communities have been impacted by
prohibition
have an opportunity and to make money in
in this this business and that isn't in
the current bill so leads me to ask why
do we have those hundred thousand dollar
fees we're much happier with those when
they were going to an obvious good cause
that we supported and now I would prefer
to see them be eliminated or at least
reduced or maybe
use for something
that would be awesome
it's a couple of quick clarifications
from questions that have been asked I
took a few notes so I did send you a
chart with all of the tax rates from
neighboring states you should have that
in your inboxes it was misstated
by a few previous speakers but really
the neighboring states have an effective
tax rate of around 20 percent each in
Mass it's a 10.75 percent retail Tax
Plus a 6.25 general sales tax
and that gets you to 17 and then they
have a three percent local option tax
that gets it to 20 percent
in Vermont it's uh 14 cannabis sales tax
six percent general sales tax 20 retail
tax very straightforward
Maine is much more complicated taxing
flower trim immature plants and seeds
each at a different rate that's
complicated for the reasons you've
already heard
um
quickly with regard to the quality of
outdoor cannabis I think a lot of people
will want to grow outdoors in Vermont
there was a tremendous interest in small
cultivator licenses being outdoors and
the problem with that is not outdoor
cannabis the problem with that was a
failure of their independent lab testing
system and that's why independent lab
testing is the most important
aspect of any regulated cannabis
business
this was a grower that had come online
that was using a fungicide or at least
was using a sprayer that still had
residue from a fungicide probably a
sprayer that had been used in the
illicit market for many years but was
now being used in the illicit market and
that cannabis somehow actually got to
the store shelves without being
independently lab tested it was a big
mess up from a inventory tracking seed
to sail tracking
scenario but it's not if this product
had been tested it would have failed and
it would not have been sold so as long
weather cannabis has grown indoors or
Outdoors there is a lot of risk of
contaminants
cannabis will never be misted as we
heard earlier because that would cause
it to develop mold once cannabis is is
dried and cured you do not want to add
more moisture to it mold is something
you're always trying to
to prevent but there's a risk of heavy
metals pesticides mold and all sorts of
things the only way to fix that is to
have every product sold be tested and
I'm confident we can achieve that Within
within the current bill
so one last comment uh we've heard gummy
bears mentioned a few times I just want
to make it really clear there's no State
selling gummy bears for cannabis uh we
the Fruit Chews we sell at Prime ATC are
little squares they can't every state
that I know of has rules that that
prohibit these products being designed
to resemble
uh characters animals anything that
could be appealing to children and and
often they have to have a cannabis leaf
with an exclamation point or some other
symbol stamped right on them so no gummy
bears worms cartoons or anything like
that and I would be
happy to conclude there and take any
questions I'm guessing you'll have
probably have them representative yes
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
you suggest taxing Imports right now
even though it's not a problem I thought
that's what I thought I heard you say
that it's going to come the interstate
commerce so take care of it now
and there's been a suggestion of
applying that 15 tax to whatever comes
into the state which could be retail as
opposed to wholesale
aren't we violating the interstate
commerce clause that way unless we
imputed a wholesale cost to the retail
product
thank you for the question
representative to clarify what I what I
said or what I intended to say is that
we should have a truck a tax structure
that anticipates the eventuality of
interstate commerce becoming legal in my
in my opinion a retail tax would
accomplish that because whether it came
from California or you know halfway
around the world for that matter if it's
sold at a New Hampshire retailer it
would be applied the tax uh
adding importation to the cultivation
tax would be a different way of
addressing that there would not be any
actual importation
um I don't want to get into the all of
that legality but there would be no
legal importation of cannabis until such
time as it became federally legal
representative
yes thank you madam chair
um and thank you for taking my questions
you picked up on you said something
something I picked up right away on and
I I wondered if you could
when I was reading this bill your model
was specifically targeted and I say
targeted because they're assessing you
know assesses you know a hundred ten
thousand dollar application fee ninety
thousand dollar uh licensing fee and so
now you're in the you you you're out
that money and then the bill goes on to
continue to talk about other
restrictions that your model might have
to
comply with because you have a dual we'd
have a dual purpose of that so
this bill as enacted uh you know with
with the fees and the taxes aside does
it put your model of a therapeutic model
at a disadvantage
if now we're opening up retail stores
all over
the state of New Hampshire
yeah thank you for the question that's a
that's the question exactly that we've
been wrestling with for for the last
last several months and particularly
since the bill came came out of Commerce
so
as drafted first of all last year's bill
would have put state-run stores in
direct competition with atc's tax there
would be no taxes on the state-run
stores and it certainly appeared to be
set up to destroy the therapeutic
cannabis program last year's bill would
not have allowed the atcs to transition
to for-profit so it would have been
inviting every large out-of-state
company into New Hampshire but telling
the three companies that pioneered
regulated cannabis in New Hampshire that
know you have to stay non-profit so this
bill's much better than last year's bill
on that front it would allow the atcs to
transition to for-profit so they could
compete on an even playing field with
the big companies that will inevitably
be interested in this it also sets up a
thoughtful transition for the
therapeutic cannabis program
understanding that rules are going to be
need to be updated the original bill
would have had the Cannabis commission
ultimately regulating both therapeutic
cannabis and adult use cannabis that's
one of the reasons that I preferred that
that system it's a little scary to think
of having two different regulatory
agencies that you have to answer to both
of them and if this is going to work the
rules have to be compatible between the
two systems I think I think that the
lawyer commission is not interested in
regulating therapeutic cannabis program
and I think DHHS is not interested in
having the Liquor Commission do that so
instead of figuring out how to get it
all under one
one system it will be a process of
figuring out how to make how to maintain
the viability of the therapeutic
cannabis program while rolling out adult
use cannabis there's going to be a lot
of moving parts
we were on board with those fees
initially because we understood the
dynamic and we see how this has gone in
other states there's often an interest
in helping to small businesses succeed
in this and the companies that have gone
first are expected to have
you know a first mover advantage and
it's normal to have fees to support this
kind of program because how else will
there be startup money to help small
businesses
there's nothing in this bill about
helping small businesses uh you know I
think the Liquor Commission could choose
to to write rules that make it easy and
favorable for small businesses or they
might not we heard chairman hunt say
earlier that the cultivators will be the
smallest number of licenses that's not
the way it is in a lot of other states
in Vermont there are far more
cultivators than retailers
um but I think what we want is for
businesses to have the flexibility to do
it
do what they want to do if you want to
be vertically integrated
that needs to be possible if you want to
specialize in one aspect of it that
needs to be possible if you want to
specialize in serving patients that
needs to be possible
I think all that intention is in the
bill but an awful lot is left to to rule
making and regulations
follow-up thank you madam chair just to
follow up on that and because the last
thing you said really I think is what we
have to is a big unknown is the rules
what we do know is for someone like you
to transition into retail we know you're
going to have to come up with a hundred
thousand dollars we don't know what that
will be what the rules will be for the
fees for somebody if I wanted to open it
up in an abandoned Pizza Hut you know
and sell sell marijuana what that would
be maybe it's five thousand dollars
maybe it's two thousand dollars but what
we do know here it sounds like
well I understand this right
and let me know if I'm something wrong
these fees you're actually subsidizing
the state to get their program running
and putting you at a possible
disadvantage
to some unknown versus unknown fees that
haven't even been defined yet do I
summarize that properly yeah I think
that's absolutely right I mean Most
states have seen fit to write fees uh in
into
into the legislation in some way usually
the priority being to to favor smaller
tiers and make sure the fees will be low
especially for small small-scale
cultivators the decision was made in the
last committee to not do that and and to
leave it to to a commission so now we
have no idea what those fees might be
relative to a hundred thousand dollars
should a big company uh I'm not going to
name any big companies but there there
are a lot of them out there and they're
not some of them have reputations of not
being particularly ethical and should we
I it could be a playing field that is
slanted toward them depending on how the
rules are written
representative Schoenberg
thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question
since you mentioned cultivators again
I'm back on the tax that wants to be
applied
since the proposed tax is going to be
applied at the cultivator level
are these cultivators are they
going to be strictly domestic or can
they be a subsidiary of a multinational
organization
that would
come in and set them up
and then
look at different ways to reduce their
tax obligation at the end of the process
yeah
thank you for the question so I I wanted
to give it or I think yeah I haven't
looked at this section of the bill in a
while there is a residency
requirement uh
and so you you will at least have to to
have a presence in New Hampshire if you
are a large out-of-state or
multinational corporation one of the
issues as as others have pointed out is
the courts have gotten into the habit of
striking those down
on the basis of violating the interstate
commerce clause that if it's okay for a
New Hampshire person to start a business
in New Hampshire why is it not okay for
a Massachusetts resident to start in New
Hampshire and that's part of why we
think that the whole interstate commerce
House of Cards is going to fall
representative Wheatley
thank you
going back to your
to the beginning of your
testimony the 15 of what can you tell me
a little bit about what you sell
sure yeah we we sell a wide range of
cannabis and cannabis products I direct
you to our menu but our website's down
actually this morning I was I had to
send an email back there to
notify people about that but um yeah we
we grow all of our cannabis flour some
of that is sold as flour some of it is
uh
we have Edibles ranging from Fruit Chews
to various chocolate products
um
we have Vape cartridges
concentrates
we even sell suppositories
so basically anything that could benefit
a patient we sell capsules as well
tinctures I think I've hit all the
categories now but really it's a wide
range of products and uh and we have to
make them all ourselves can I have a
follow-up thank you
um so
about the revenue generation it seems
very unclear to you uh what
you cultivate what that really uh how to
break down the value of that within your
business model but I'm assuming that
everything you sell on the retail level
has a price
and that it would be pretty easy to
apply uh tax to each of those products
you know whether it be 15 or something
else is that correct
yeah I think so I think like most
businesses we we learn what customers in
our case patients are willing to pay for
prices by putting it on the Shelf
putting it on the menu telling them it's
available if it sells at that price
that's that's the price if it doesn't
sell maybe we need to reduce the price
we also have very limited wholesaling so
atcs can sell flour to each other can
sell products to each other so sometimes
you know we we will bundle up some flour
and offer it to another ATC for sale and
maybe they bought it from us at a price
last time maybe they don't want to buy
it this time it's buyers and sellers
create prices by making transactions in
a Marketplace and that's our concern
here like these seem like they would be
imaginary transactions and therefore
who's who's going to decide uh it either
has to be
you know have to be some some Arbiter of
what is an acceptable tax rate for this
given batch of of cannabis
so it sounds like the only
Market that you can see results of
really is the retail Market
correct correct thank you
representative Phyllis thank you madam
chair this is like a follow-up to to
what we've been talking about so so we
know you have these different kinds of
products and I'm interested in the
possibility of charging
taxing at a higher rate the ones with
the higher level of THC so I'm just
wondering if you can talk about the
feasibility of doing that I you and I
also I don't understand like the
comparability
of you know just the plain cannabis and
when it turns into a gummy or you know
those are all different can tell me how
how that would work if that's what we
want to do
thank you for the question I've heard
that idea suggested I'm not aware of any
state that has actually adopted that in
part because I don't know how it would
work uh
it it seems
it seems like a recipe for a lot of
confusion and you know like first of all
inhalable products are potency is
measured and thought about differently
for any product that will be inhaled
versus any edible
product with edible products you're
talking about milligrams of THC usually
being being the
the thing that matters and for inhalable
products you're talking about a
percentage
a THC percentage
within the product so it's it's at least
uh theoretically possible but I don't
think it's theoretically even possible
to do it simply
follow-up
um I just want to ask you about there
was a study commission and they didn't
they made an estimate on revenue and one
of the factors that they used is they
made an assumption that this is just
talking about regular just cannabis
that that the average
user
um
consumed in a year
between five and eight ounces does that
sound does that
comport with your experience or what I
mean there have been a number of studies
over the years trying to quantify that
as with
other averages and with regard to
cannabis and it's really hard to talk
about averages because there will be a
small percentage of consumers who
consume quite a lot of cannabis and then
there will be a larger population of
folks who you know maybe take a puff
every once in a while or take an edible
every once in a while when they want to
get a good night's sleep and use it very
occasionally so
you know there are different categories
of users and different rates of
consumption much as there are with
alcohol or tobacco and it's it's hard to
speak with a broad brush about about the
Cannabis Market
offhand I don't know I will say that
study commission was was several years
ago there are probably better Market
estimates I know there are better Market
estimates available uh Vermont just
rolled out its adult use market and they
did a really terrific market analysis
that's available from the Vermont
cannabis Control Board website they
looked at
you know they hired an economist and
they looked at you know how much do we
think people consume who live in Vermont
how much do we think people consume who
are tourists who visit Vermont or who
pass through Vermont or who live in a
state like guess what New Hampshire that
still does not have retail cannabis how
many grandstanders for example are going
to go so they did a really detailed
deep dive there and I think those are
probably going to be better estimates
than than anything that was in our
commission report a few years ago
representative ulery
thank you madam Sharon it looks like
this would be the last question
um
regarding the
multinationals that was brought up
earlier now are you referring to a
multinational would manual that grows it
out of uh bicep the plot grows the stuff
and sells it or are you talking about a
multinational like
Monsanto or DeKalb that produces seeds
thank you for the question I'm talking
about cannabis companies that may have
started in the U.S or may have started
in Canada or may have started somewhere
else but that have grown aggressively
and participate in all aspects of the
Cannabis industry from growing
manufacturing and retailing and you know
in in my last job I was trying to pass
legalization laws and often these these
companies would send their own lobbyists
and they were trying to pass very
different laws than the ones that I was
trying to pass they wanted very high
barriers to entry massive fees keep home
grow legal let's only have a few big
companies do this
so you're saying that the the straw
person multinational
does anything it can to make money on
this product yes I am saying that thank
you
representative thank you just quickly
you said you sent us all on a chart of
all the taxes and and that are added on
in our region and it hasn't come yet
oh I'm sorry I sent it to the Ways and
Means Committee address while I was
sitting back there so maybe uh it's not
maybe you got stuck in a spam folder or
something I know that happened in the
last committee
if you'd be comfortable uh there's also
an online testimony portal and that
really we make sure we see that so if
you could do that as well
oh it isn't spam so thank you there's
two ways to get us that the email
address and the online portal so thank
you very much any other questions
great thank you so much and just it's it
obviously we're trying to cram a lot of
information in here we've got uh two
more quick people testifying and then
what I think we should do is uh end the
public hearing and if it's okay with the
agencies I'd love to schedule a work
session and have you come back another
date you know dra DHHS liquor all of you
to come back on a work session we can
really get in the weeds a little if
that's okay I'd like to represent uh
recognize Dr Joe Hannon former
representative
welcome
good morning
still uh thank you madam chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Joseph Hannan I was a public member of
the Cannabis study commission that you
heard about earlier back in 2018
I'm in support of this bill I do have a
few things that I'd like to address
about the taxation aspects of it you've
heard a lot of people already talk about
the rooms of meals tax and a retail
level sales tax I definitely support
that strongly even though our commission
years ago thought that a wholesale tax
would be a good idea there have been a
lot of states that have legalized since
and we've seen what has actually
happened with some of those taxation
agendas in other states
um you know where the revenue goes is
important uh the ease of how the taxes
are collected and who collects them are
important but the primary concern we
should be thinking about is the
sustainability of the businesses and the
ability to serve the consumers that
they're providing to
so you know the primary thing we need to
do is make sure that these businesses
don't go out of business because what's
the purpose of having a tax system if
they're not going to be around
um
you know we're in a state with higher
energy costs colder drier climate most
of the year we have a smaller consumer
base than most States and cultivation is
very difficult we've heard outdoor and
even indoor is very expensive
uh import taxes would not be legal once
interstate commerce is is going on we
don't have border checkpoints in New
Hampshire even though some people think
it may be a good idea with our Southern
border we don't have that
um
you know another thing is uh we heard
about cultivation taxes being applied to
hemp because the seeds are considered
cannabis according to this bill uh hemp
products are are legally able to be
grown in New Hampshire and other states
and their uses are much greater than
just consuming uh they can be used as
food uh fuel textiles uh you know
Fabrics ropes you name it there's a
whole host of things that hemp products
could be used for so we don't want to
get that stuck in the taxation scheme
um you know that we also heard about
charging by weight and if you have
um the weight of a product is the
primary mode of Taxation the goal of the
people growing it and selling it is
going to be get the most bang for your
buck you're going to make the strongest
most highest concentrated THC product
you can so you're paying less of a tax
per weight uh we don't have that with
beer and wine because there are limits
on how much alcohol is allowed in beer
and wine so unless you have a very
tiered system of you know 10 to 15
percent 15 to 30 30 to 60 80 percent and
different tax rates for each amount of
strength of THC in a product it's going
to be almost impossible to do it by
weight unless your goal is to just make
it incentivize for stronger products
we've seen that in the illegal Market
with things like fentanyl if we tax the
illicit Market of Fentanyl and heroin
like we were planning to do when they by
weight and cannabis
fennel would be much easier to to sell
because you wouldn't pay as much tax
because it's 50 times stronger than a
comparable dose of a smaller product so
if you're just comparing it that way
it's it doesn't make sense to do that
um and another thing is uh it was
briefly mentioned it's not a major
concern but talents uh opting out should
not benefit from the business that they
don't want to allow in their talent so I
don't think it's it's a good idea to
reward towns to say well we don't want
your business here but we'll take your
money so I think that's a good thing to
leave in the bill
um and lastly we have to look at the I
you know the New Hampshire Advantage you
know we we consider ourselves low tax
that's a big Advantage we have right now
that Advantage goes to Vermont Maine and
Massachusetts because it's illegal here
so it's imperative that this goes
through so that we can actually apply
the New Hampshire advantage to this
industry so we're not losing money not
losing jobs and this isn't a ways and
means concern but we heard a lot of
concerns about driving under the
influence and all these other things
right now we expect people to drive
further and longer to get their cannabis
to bring it back to New Hampshire that's
what's happening the reality so if we
want to decrease that I think we need to
have it legalized uh in State uh and and
lastly we have to think about uh what if
there's mail order that's allowed at the
federal level uh what do we do then
we're going to be in a situation where
it's going to be like Amazon
um you know I grew up in Philadelphia
and I love the soft pretzels I know a
guy he can get us a soft pretzels here I
don't have to pay the rooms and meals
tax if I did that but I don't I don't do
it I have a guy who
just gives me free pretzels sorry
um anyway uh
don't want to incriminate myself
um you know and the other thing is you
know the same thing with other products
uh we're we're trying to tax something
based on uh quality and people are
paying for different products if you
want to tax at the cultivation level
that would be like taxing not beer or
wine or the the product that's already
uh made it would be like taxing flour
and bakeries you know a baker can do
take some flour make a three dollar loaf
of bread or they can take it and make it
into a a 35 pastry at a five-star
restaurant how do you tax that if you're
just taxing flour uh it's it's something
that really needs to be addressed so I
think the takeaway is I I do believe we
should go back to rooms and meals uh
model uh we heard testimony that
there'll be more cultivate there are
more cultivators in Vermont than there
are the retailers and
um it's it's not something that we don't
know how to do we do it now uh it's
already being done it's not a new tax
and I think it could be easily applied
to this and it would be the most fair
and Equitable way of of taxing a product
in a state without negatively
influencing how things are grown how
strong we expect things to be made or
how safe a product it'll be I think
consumers will be the ultimate Arbiter
of what something should cost and I
think we need to allow that and allow
that free market to occur I'd be happy
to take any questions and I know it's
almost lunch time so
whatever you want
I think we're all set for now thank you
thank you
okay uh chair will recognize Frank Knack
I hope I get that right scl-a-c-l-u of
New Hampshire welcome
uh Madam chair members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify my name is Frank Knack I'm the
policy director with the ACLU of New
Hampshire
um we're we're in in support of HB 639
for two real reasons one from a harm
reduction perspective and a second from
a racial Justice perspective many of
these policy um
policy decisions for the reason that we
support this I think are outside the
scope of what you all want to talk about
today so I'll try and focus on a few
Revenue related issues one is the shadow
tax that prohibition currently has in
New Hampshire and so we heard a little
bit about this when it was being
introduced so our national office a few
years back did an economic analysis of
the cost of marijuana enforcement so
because when there's an arrest there are
multiple actors involved from law
enforcement courts
um other administrators and it has a
severe cost and so looking at the number
of arrests in New Hampshire last year
which was over 1100 and plugging that
into the methodology that our national
office uh created we're spending about
2.6 million dollars every year on the
enforcement of just marijuana possession
laws alone in New Hampshire and so
taking aside the revenue that could be
coming in just looking at what we're
actually spending now on marijuana
possession and that 2.6 million does not
include any of the collateral harms of a
Marijuana arrest and so that makes it
harder for an individual individual to
get housing to get employment around
child custody issues ETC and all those
that have additional costs that are
impacting our state and I did a quick
search of the collateral consequences
that attach to any misdemeanor offense
in New Hampshire according to the
National inventory of collateral
consequences there are 99 separate
collateral consequences that attach
mandatorily attached to any misdemeanor
conviction in New Hampshire and so again
those are all additional harms that are
having a cost on our communities and the
second piece I want to quickly touch on
is the fiscal note and so I think we
heard from the Chiefs that they expect
there would be additional law
enforcement costs and if you actually
look at the data the opposite issue so
when the chief spoke last year and
testified on this bill with with a with
more testimony they talked about quote
unquote spillover crime is that when
Massachusetts legalized when Vermont
legalized when Maine legalized there was
spillover crime because those States had
legalized and it impacted New Hampshire
and so we wanted to have a fact-based
discussion about this and so we actually
looked at crime stats data from the New
Hampshire Department of Safety uh
beginning in 2016 when Maine legalized
2017 when Mass legalized 2018 when
Vermont legalized and so when they
testified about that last year crime in
New Hampshire between the first year of
legalization and that most recent data
was down 22 percent fast forward one
year crime is now down 26 percent so the
notion that there's any type of
spillover crime happening because of
marijuana and its increasing law
enforcement
um requirements is is not based in
actual data and also we heard we've
heard concerns about and we see in the
fiscal note around youth use around
traffic fatality so I don't want to get
into the weeds too much and and we have
citations that a number of academic and
medical journals uh going through many
of these but I'll just point to one
quickly around youth use because I think
that's an issue that comes up quite
often and so this is an article from the
association
um from the journal the medical America
the Journal of the American Medical
Association back in 2019 and what they
found was this is regarding youth use of
marijuana marijuana laws recreational
marijuana laws were associated with an
eight percent decrease in the odds of
marijuana use and a nine percent
decrease in the odds of frequent
marijuana use by Youth and so the notion
that we're going to see some huge uptick
is again not supported by the evidence
and so when you're looking at that in
the fiscal note we're not seeing that in
other states happy to answer any
questions
that's great thank you uh representative
Ulrich
which would be the better form of
Taxation the 15 tax on the uh sale at or
the growth
or a sales tax so we were a member of
the Coalition that came up with the uh
worked on the original Bill language so
we would support the original meals tax
but we're also we're in support of the
current version of this bill
other questions
seeing none thank you so much
okay I have a pink card from Jenny
O'Higgins from DHHS are you still hear
Jenny Jenny would you be open to joining
us at a work session or is there
something specific you'd like to just
say right now
thank you so much I appreciate that and
then uh Bruce and Keane from the dra is
there something specific you wanted to
say for the record would you would you
join us for the work session work
session okay now I don't have a card
from The Liquor Commission
um would you be open to joining us at a
work session okay that'd be great
representative all me
thank you and I think on Matt Simon's
chart probably is only for our region
no it's for the whole country
oh good that answers my question
okay that was a long public hearing for
us uh yes representative fellows yes I'd
just like to ask if you can have our
researcher put together some information
about
um what I've been hearing people say
something about when we have do licenses
and
certifications that somehow
those amounts are only supposed to
support what it takes to to
um
issue and to do inspections related to
those licenses we heard it for oplc and
we heard it again here I just I I just
don't really understand that concept we
have some resident experts in this
committee on that topic I believe so
during our work session we can talk
about that with the difference between a
fee is an attacks that part I understand
what what I'm what was new to me was to
hear director Courtney say that it's
somehow it's illegal to establish fees
for a license that that raise more money
than is needed to operate the program
which would include the actual licensing
and expense expenditures for
um you know inspectors and supporting
whatever board is connected to that
license that's the part that I don't
understand okay great
um I don't have any other pink cards to
testify on this bill
okay with that I will go ahead represent
the balmy
on with regard to the previous question
on we were taught long ago in this
committee that there's 125 percent rule
on 25 percent for General administrative
costs of the state but
on I also had a run-in with the
Comptroller
on dedicated funds A couple of years ago
who we had a dedicated fund which is
still now charging uh charging enough
that 70 percent of it lapses to the
state every two years on and she said
that as long as this was written into
the law which it was that it is legal
and that that you can't touch it without
going and putting in a special Bill to
change that law now I'd like to get the
Comptroller in here to try and get that
figured out because olpc is also going
in the other direction
and I think it it doesn't just apply to
here it also applies generally to how we
handle things
thank you okay uh with that we will
close the public hearing and House Bill
639 and we will schedule a work session
so please all of you who are here if
you'd like to join us for that that way
maybe we can pick your brain a little
bit more thank you very much so when the
committee will take a break until one
and then we have another public hearing
at that time thank you
assessed after the the fees uh that the
fund balances and the fees be assessed
after the uh passage of the law to make
sure that they were uh consistent with
the me with the
um purposes of the chapter uh then I'd
be comfortable with that but simply
saying any excess fees should go into
the into the general fund and not having
further oversight of that I think is
would run into the same problem where uh
if the fees are really not uh
in line with the amount that they're
need that that's needed to fund the
program and if they're excessive then
the fees should be reduced if the um
if they are uh substantially ins um
under what's needed then the feeds would
need to be increased
but I don't think we can really tell
until we make a change that uh to
clarify the administration of them
follow up follow up
okay you're establishing a non-lapsing
fund
it's non-lapsing so
you're not going to get that information
because the money just sits there
so unless we have some mechanism that
says after we do all of our job we have
ten dollars left over what are you going
to do with that ten dollars is is the
question right uh so uh if if the if in
the Years work ten dollars is left over
after uh the approximate the fund the
the those fees generate about
um five to six thousand a hundred
thousand dollars per year uh and if ten
dollars is left over after a year then
that goes that can you know certainly
carry over to the next year where there
might be a slight shortfall uh if we're
if it turns out that it is only taking
three hundred thousand dollars to uh to
run the program then
and do all the necessary work of the
program uh then then the fees should be
reconsidered
uh if it turns out that it's actually
taking a million dollars to uh
to run the program the fees should also
be reconsidered but if it's within say
25 percent uh then I think that that
would be I think there's 125 rule in
terms of what uh what fees are you know
the the the margin between the amount
drop brought in by fees and the uh and
uh what the fund should have in it
uh do you have another follow-up yep go
ahead
so you would not be adverse to something
like uh implementing what other
non-lapsing plans have at the 125 rule
uh I I think if it's consistent with
what's done with other non-lapsing funds
I think that would be appropriate
representative fellows I'm sorry first
and then we'll go around yes
um can you tell me what kind of problem
you're supporting you're trying to fix
with this because I I'm just really
concerned
that I see it in this spill but I've
also seen it in another context that it
it's picking apart the very little tasks
some very little tasks within an agency
because instead of looking at it more
holistically because like you've been
they've been doing this job for a long
time I'm sure so are they going to not
be able to do it for some reason without
unless they retain These funds well the
problem that was
the the that was brought out during the
study committee was that in fact they
hadn't been doing the job that uh the
department chapter 431 tasks the
department with analyzing fertilizers
and lime to make sure that the content
is consistent with the labels this is a
consumer protection issue it is also an
Environmental Protection issue
because if the uh if you expect your
fertilizer to be 10 10 10 and you're
only getting 888 then you're being
shorted
uh and that is and there are penalties
for that but you actually there needs to
be a sample of the fertilizer tested on
a regular basis to determine whether
that's being whether the producers are
actually following their labels uh and
uh that testing with the exception of a
couple of complaints in the last year
was not being done
so the department was in fact not
carrying through its obligations under
the statute and one of the reasons was
that the resources of the department
were being diverted to other programs
that are in a separate in different
chapters and for 43 upon one was not
being actually overseen the way it was
supposed to be uh if the money is
dedicated to chapter 431 then that's
what the money needs to be spent for and
the resources need to be spent for
okay a bunch of hands representative all
me and then representative spilsbury
next
thank you
um
I seem to remember from the dedicated
funds committee which is the one that
looks at these things
and that there are several other
dedicated
um agricultural materials
on funds uh there are dead
um there are dedicated funds associated
with pesticides uh there are dedicated
funds associated with
um
the sum of the revenue from uh animal
feed goes into uh the fund that uh
deals with weights and measures another
portion of that that goes into
um a fund that deals with animal health
by funding the veterinary pathology
Veterinary Diagnostic lab uh and I'm not
sure there may be
there I know that there are you know
there are a number of different fees
that the department charges I'm not sure
exactly
how many of those go into General the
general fund how many of those go into
dedicated funds uh and uh this bill was
specific specifically came out of the
soil conditioner study committee so we
were just dealing with chapter 431 it
was a recommendation specific from that
study committee we did not do an overall
study of dedicated funds in the entire
department
thank you and could I just ask also sure
on
would any of the general
fund money that goes to the Department
of Agriculture be reduced because you're
taking off this smallish piece
um I do not know that is I I would it
would it would seem appropriate that uh
if the department was not did not need
to ask for that roughly half a million
dollars in order to be able to run the
um run in order in order to oversee 431
then they wouldn't need to ask for that
as a as an additional line item it would
depend on what exactly what they asked
for would depend on
the balance of
um what they their program costs and
um and the revenues and I don't know
I don't have access I I did not look
into the details of those costs and
revenues
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair
from what I'm hearing I believe that you
are recognizing that the there could be
an evolving imbalance between the fees
generated in the costs to fulfill the
purpose you can go in either direction
so I would have thought that the way to
maintain a dynamic balance between the
fee and the anticipated costs is through
the biennial
budgeting process what's the incentive
if we have a dedicated fund where the
fees can accumulate
to periodically revisit and
re-re-rebalance the fee versus the costs
and I have a second question if I may
default okay so um the uh
one uh I don't know that we could it
could be amended so that there was some
rebalancing mechanism included I don't
know if that's generally done with uh
with dedicated funds and uh what I um
but if that is an uh an ordinary
practice of this committee then uh that
would be appropriate
um and uh if there is
um if there is a marked imbalance in in
terms of a shortfall that is something
that the the commissioner of the
department could say okay this uh
dedicated fund covers this proportion of
our costs for the program but we're
going to need more uh and from the
general fund uh and certainly there are
programs in the Department of
Agriculture that are supported more by
general fund dollars and other poor than
other portions uh if it is if the fees
are substantially too high then we could
revisit those fees in a future biennium
yeah my follow-up
do you not think that your argument or
your concern if it was applied broadly
across the realm of state government
would imply that every place that
there's a fee there should be a
dedicated fund associated with it
and I think the norm is actually more
the way the law stands currently where
the fees go into the general fund and
then they're subject to biennial
appropriation
I think that uh in a case where the fees
clear clearly have not been uh reapplied
appropriately then what we are looking
at is a is de facto uh
disproportionate taxation rather than
uh rather than management of fees if if
a fertilizer manufacturer
pays us pays a registration fee on their
on what they're selling into New
Hampshire
and they expect that the effect of what
they're paying is going to be that
there's going to be a Level Playing
Field so there will be testing to make
sure that nobody is cheating
and the it turns out that that service
is not being provided by the state they
are paying a section and that that money
is going to say an Organic certification
program
they are paying a tax that is going to
some other purpose than what they're
paying the fee for and we need as
legislators to make sure that our
revenues are being used honestly
representative ulrey
thank you madam chair
okay not that familiar with four
31.
other than
having known Don Wilson for many many
years
the question is
is every product sold in New Hampshire
required to be tested or do we trust the
label and
um the department of Sean's Department
Deals Only with complaints
the statute says that it shall be tested
it does not lay out the specific it does
not say that every product shall be
tested every year but it but uh the
statute essentially indicates that a
representative sample should be
uh should be tested on a regular basis
if it's not required to be tested every
year since shall be tested but it
doesn't say why or when or how
does not seem more reasonable to First
mandate an expense and then pay for that
expense than to just
pay for something that isn't being done
because it's only being done on demand
well the problem is that it should not
that by Statute it should not be done
only On Demand by Statute it should be
done
on a regular basis
and
the department
was failing uh for a number of years to
carry through their requirement to test
it on a regular basis
and there are all sorts of reasons why
the department is failing to do that
which I you can discuss with the
commissioner and
predecessor uh his when he told me that
when his predecessor handed the
department over to him she told him that
the department was basically in triage
mode uh and that does not
it is has improved since then but there
are there are a number of
problems with the regulatory
functions of the department that have to
do with irregularities and funding The
Organic certification program charges a
fee that is minuscule compared to the
cost of uh of operating that program
uh the so essentially what was happening
was that other
fees were being used to prop up that
program
representative homie
thank you
would you believe that under Steve
Taylor
he bought bit every nickel in that
department
and that is before the predecessor
and he
um he's a very frugal Yankee
and that
when I was on
Finance I was on division one and the
weights and measures people came to us
to try to ask for a new machine because
they could no longer reliably do weights
and measures and we asked them why
didn't you put that in the budget and
they said he wouldn't let us
so the department has been
been
shortchanging all of the stuff it's
supposed to do for a very long time now
I would believe that and would you uh
have you ever watched the finance
committee look at the budget of the
Department of Agriculture I watched part
of it one year and uh
I think it was the first year that
commissioner Jasper was
um was was working on it and I was
pleased to see that commissioner Jasper
was actually arguing that his Department
should have more money rather than
saying oh okay give us less
follow-up but my point was did they
actually look at any of the
individual operations
I do not know
exactly what the budget process was
um and uh and I I know that
um the
current director of regulatory Services
has been more vocal in terms of speaking
about what needs are not being met and
has been bringing that to commissioner
Jasper but I don't know the details all
the budgetary budgetary details of it
representative fellows
thank you ma'am cheer
not sure where to even start with this I
one thing I know from being on the
commission that
recommended how to license mushroom
Harvesters is is a and that was like
four years ago I know that they have an
issue with their database for the whole
department or or you know lots of things
that they have to keep track of and that
seems to me that I've heard
that the governor was
I think agreeable to giving them some
money to to get that put put money in
the budget to get that database updated
I think I heard that when commissioner
Jasper was up for his renomination as
commissioner in the spring
and then I also look at this and I see
that you're telling us that they only
did two fertilizer samples last year but
the fiscal note says they did 4498
samples or this says fertilizer res
registration program but well okay maybe
that's it they have to register
their fertilizer and
and but it only gets
sampled only two out of 5 000 were
sampled I I just the whole the whole
thing here is just
not fitting together for me I understand
that they that they need a new database
and that that's mentioned in the fiscal
note but if this is all a mechanism to
get there get them a database I don't
think we need to go there I think that
that just needs to get approved in the
budget so do you agree with that or can
you shed some light on that I can shed
some light on that the uh database is us
is a different bill it went before
Finance last week Finance retained it
with the intention of putting in the
budget uh and that database is the
um the so essentially what that bill
does is it provides the setup cost for
the database the maintenance costs for
the database will be paid for out of
fees uh some of and that database would
be covering more than just the
fertilizer but the fees would be
um
that are produced by fertilizer and the
fees that are produced by other
regulatory
programs would contribute towards the
cost of doing the database maintenance
so uh so that database is something that
is desperately needed and uh it is being
done in the budget uh in terms of uh the
handling of the fees uh the
um
the way that this uh the the way that
this bill is written in terms in terms
of
um managing the fees is that some of the
cost of the some of the fees that come
in through this will go towards
um maintaining the database some will go
towards the costs of doing the product
analysis some some of the costs some
will go towards the process of doing the
product registrations so every time a
fertilizer manufacturer or distributor
wants to sell
uh fertilizer in the state of New
Hampshire they have to submit uh a a
label and an application to do that and
then those labels are uh processed by
the the people in the department and uh
there's a fee that is a that for for
that process of registering which is 75
per registration uh and uh that uh that
fee is intended to cost to cover the
cost of both processing the
um the registrations up front
maintaining them on record and doing
periodic analysis of the product to make
sure that it actually meets the label so
the reason for putting this into a
specific fund is to make sure that these
monies are in fact used for those
purposes
oh
so
until like does do we need to be
you know registering the fertilizer
that's a policy issue but just in terms
of the money
if if the general fund is going to pay
for that database
doesn't it make sense that some of the
money from these fees should be lapsed
to the general fund and otherwise you're
going to get into this like I think it's
called cost accounting where you nitpick
like every little minute of like an
employee's time and that I mean that's
you're going to have to hire people just
to keep track of that and I'm not going
to say anything more so essentially the
setting up of the database is a capital
expense
and uh it makes sense to pay for that
out of the general fund
uh the maintenance the ongoing
maintenance of the database is a
maintenance expense and that will come
out of the fee income uh from uh that
would be in this dedicated fund and in
other funds that the department has
access to for their other registration
and Licensing programs
representative play
yes from your testimony which I just
mislaid there's a line in there about uh
um the fees aren't generating enough to
cover the cost of testing and that's why
so so little is being done and
paraphrasing
why aren't you here asking for an
increase in the fee
okay so
um the
it's not that the fees are insufficient
to do the testing is that the testing
has not been has not been
are done and the reason that the testing
has not been done is that the resources
for that testing were diverted to other
programs
other questions from the committee
okay thank you so much thank you
all right I do not have any more pink
cards
no one else is here to speak on this
bill no okay so we will now close the
public hearing on House Bill 494.
all right guys good work today uh safe
travels tomorrow everything is canceled
for here for tomorrow
everything
I believe so I did a quick I was looking
at an email from Paul Smith I'm pretty
sure everything is off tomorrow
so
um
enjoy yourself and your snow day plan to
be here at 11 A.M on Wednesday
representative Spielberg
so our agenda for Wednesday includes
executive session on the cannabis bill
keep in mind whenever we know we're
gonna have an exact session I try to
list as many things as possible so if
we're ready we can do it I wasn't sure
just trying to get to know what you
think we will be yeah I I wasn't sure
how the committee would feel about the
bill
um and it to me it's very apparent that
we need a work session on that bill
because we didn't even hear from any of
the agencies that are impacted by it so
uh we will schedule a work session on
that so we will not exec six things am I
correct that we have until March 30th to
get out a second I believe so because of
the second committee so work session
that includes a good robust discussion
after we hear from the agencies that
would be great it would be yeah be part
of that whole thing to be go through
that
um it's obviously a big bill
um but if we try to keep focused on our
piece
um but still there's still a lot to
think about there uh so yeah I and what
I don't know is when we can schedule
that work session because we don't know
if we're going to be here next week in
session for two days or three days so I
don't know how much you can do here but
yeah go ahead so I just procedurally I
don't know
um what happens when we're the second
committee to get a bill
and when we were the first committee we
retained a whole bunch of those can we
retain something when we're we get it as
a second coming that is an appropriate
motion yes thank you that is option
that's always an option for any Bill
same with the one we just heard yeah
it's an option
um or we may we'll have to see where the
room goes after we have I think we I
think on that one it sounded like we
needed a work session I wasn't sure if
we did or not but it sounds like we
absolutely do yeah
so so right now just you know what I'm
thinking is well we have to do an exec
session on Wednesday we must do that
right now it's scheduled for 11.
please contact me if you think 11 is
going to be a huge hardship for you
because what I can do is come in open
the exact session and then immediately
uh recess it until we think we can get
people here so if it's if representative
spilsbury gets 18 inches and can't get
here till noon maybe we can just but but
we have to do it and I need you here so
um I'll try to be a little flexible but
we got to get it done because then we
got session at 9am the following day so
just be aware of that and then for
whatever happens at the exact session on
Wednesday of course please be
pre-prepared with what a committee uh
report might look like at least sketch
something out so that we're not you know
here till midnight huh right represent
Ames did you have something to add
yeah I was just on the on the cannabis
bill
um
I think you know we may divide in One
Direction or another uh who knows
um but it's really complicated and
they're clearly uh some technical issues
with the bill
so I think it behooves all of us that
are interested in maybe getting
something done
to try to
get a handle on those technical changes
you know there are mistakes in the bill
we
got a list of them today from various
people actually and they're not not
because of the choice between 15 and
a half percent there just because there
are mistakes partly in the shift from
the 15a from the eight and a half to the
15 I think there were mistakes made but
uh so so I'm just
flagging that we've got a job in our
hands no matter which way we go
on the big issues to get a
a bill that's
at least fixes the mistakes and goes
forward on one front or another or it
goes forward with a divide I don't know
and that's a very good point because
there there are some we you know there's
some wording issues and syntax issues uh
we have our rep our committee researcher
here
the interestingly the liquor
Commissioners who were here did not even
give us a pink card it's like they
didn't want to testify but would they be
able to do that deep dive amongst them I
mean in their in their agency to do the
Deep dive and help us identify and the
fixes that are necessary do they have
that capacity
well
I'm assuming that's the right agency
what do we think no no we don't
side by side of the original bill
and the bill that came out of the
committee
I was just going to suggest the same
thing but I would make it a three column
last year's Bill HP 1598 which had an
Enterprise model
the bill that was introduced which I
have not read but I gathered from this
morning follows the meals and rooms
retail level tax model
and the amended Bill these are three
fundamentally different concepts of how
to promote and enjoy some of the revenue
from the industry that I think that's
really where our time and attention
needs to focus
I'm not sure we're going to have the
staff available to do that and if this
is a topic of great interest to you I
would encourage you to do your own Deep
dive and go to your own personal experts
on this if if representative abrami is
someone you consider an expert because
he's done the work and the commission
I would encourage you to reach out to
him and maybe he will come back to us
when we do our work session but if
there's other people like that encourage
them to help us because I I'm looking at
Jennifer and I'm thinking there's only
so much we can ask of the staff at this
time of the year yes representative is
it possible to ask LBA I mean to give to
give representative or abrami's
you know hand out give that to them and
ask LBA not LBA L um legislative
Services OLS ask OLS to look at it again
I mean they it's a long Bill any anybody
working on its you know it's
understandable there would be some you
know mistakes in it but and they could
at least
enough
I'm not sure representative ulery
weren't limited as to what we can do on
the policy in the side by side would
show policy changes we're limited to the
revenue uh questions
so some of the corrections that uh Pat
has put in
our syntax and and we should correct
them and make that and uh perhaps have
John as the co-signer on the uh uh
Amendment if it's put forward because
that would have the input of uh our
Commerce Committee
uh so it would be policy coming from
them as a uh the scrivener's note type
of uh an amendment that can be taken
care of the questions that we're limited
to are as to the revenue generation the
15 applied at the core or a sales tax
would be better uh and then there would
have to be a justification for this one
or that one uh whichever we come up with
um
I think that may be
a division of work assignments that
maybe
beneficial to correcting all of the
problems within the bill not stepping on
any toes if you will and getting the the
thing
back on the floor even if it has to be a
floor Amendment for some of the
Crossing of T's and died in your eyes
but
I'm offering that as a suggestion to the
committee because we're limited on this
bill as to what we can talk about which
is
money
not
Crossing T's and Doty knives but money
so I just
10 cents representative almond inflation
yeah I believe the representative Ames
has probably already found all of the
editing problems
I was talking about it the day after we
got the bill
but on
aside from that on money includes
Appropriations yes it does because the
finance committee doesn't get to see
this yeah
and also
um
I think it would help if all of us tried
to
segregate out
the tax structure versus the
appropriation side versus any editing
things we think somebody might have
missed and have them with them whenever
we've managed to get to the work session
so that we aren't going from one topic
to the other forgetting what we just
said
yeah
it was Ames did you have something else
yeah just
I I would welcome that uh
side by side the two pieces I I agree
with you that the bill last year or
whenever it was two years ago when last
year I guess
um
there was a big policy issue there it
was an Enterprise
model
and
I think were probably pieces that this
year's Bill two versions but the main
thing was it was run by The Liquor
Commission that's where the debate was
that's where we got hung up that's where
that's because why it died in the end I
think but I would set that aside
so I'm looking ahead to a calendar and
uh if we're going to do house session
three days next week uh I guess I'm
looking at Tuesday the 28th
to do work sessions
particularly on 639
and and then we can also list exec
session that day if already great but
then listing an exact session the
following day the 29th
um and hopefully get it done on the 29th
but that would give us two days yes
representative fellows
I didn't bring my calendar with me but
I'm pretty sure the 28th is a day that I
sent you an email about
you remember I had
that's I'm not available that day
yep that is the day
well we're kind of the only thing is
we're kind of getting shy on time
um
I can't imagine you guys would want to
be here next Friday
um other thoughts on dates
right do you mean Friday this week or
Friday next week we can't do it this
Friday because we wouldn't have time to
notice it
um but even next week I don't know about
you but those long house session days
are exhausting I don't know if I could
do another day after that no so what
about Monday May no March 27th
okay I'm sorry I end up loss now
um so we could potentially do a work
session on Monday March 27th
particularly focusing on House Bill 639
we can organize ourselves hopefully to
talk about it in the I think there's
three or four different segments that
were just mentioned one what are the
scrivener errors we've got to fix two
what's the tax rate three what what are
we taxing for where's the money going
right are those four categories we're
focusing on
and you know kind of address those one
by one having the agencies here to help
us
work through that and any other experts
you would think would be necessary so so
another thought in terms of like the
just the I guess you're calling them
Scribner areas just what they use the
wrong word or something the wrong tense
or grammatic or they put it in the wrong
place like one was labeled a c and it
should have been a b yeah so I think I I
think it's important but I don't think
we should
I don't even maybe at the end if we have
nothing else to do I just think we ought
to focus on the other two pieces because
the bill still has to go to the Senate
yeah some people are very very good at
that and if you are please do that on
all these bills be you know another
element that I think we talked about too
is the whole
rule making and the fees where the fees
coming from so that's another topic we
really have to focus on you know what
level of fee is appropriate so if we
could kind of do it in those categories
at least I think that'd be helpful your
thoughts
representative I I don't think we
explored next Monday what I'm recalling
from HP 1598 is there was a series of
complex amendments
um discussed proposed and considered
I don't see any realistic opportunity to
get into that kind of dynamic if we're
meeting two consecutive days at the end
if we're meeting the you know the 27th
and 28th there's no way we're going to
be able to turn amendments around we'll
probably end up retaining it if that's
uh the calendar we follow so what about
the next two Mondays it gives you a week
between sessions to try and refashion
what you think the solution for
something might be
we have this done in time for to go to
the floor again we voted on which is
actually happened
yes as long as we get it done
um you know March 30th is our absolute
deadline but March 29th because we're
going to have to have everything done to
the clerk and so forth so that's why I'm
trying to get there we do need to push
it along but I also I'm just trying to
be a little sensitive to the fact that
next week could be really tough
a lot of days here a lot of hours here
so yeah
for them to do amendments
and then maturity in life
could be an option yeah
no I don't think there are any because
of the deadline is being that weak right
yeah
would the other important deadline we
have is next week that's why it could be
the Tuesday Wednesday Thursday thing
it's a little bit challenging let me see
if I can get a little bit more
information from the speaker on what he
thinks about next Tuesday I certainly
don't mind meeting next week but if
we're going to be here three long days
of session I just want to you to be
aware of that if we're not going to have
session on Tuesday then maybe we do want
to come in Monday or Tuesday for half a
day and start percolating deep and
getting a deeper dive on this
um because I'm not you know I think it's
a great idea because we might need some
more time for if these amendments are
big
but I just don't want to overwhelm us
that's all so let me see if I can find
out
well we're talking about both of them
but so there's a chance that we'll have
session next Tuesday
and Wednesday we're definitely having it
Wednesday and Thursday
right so let me see if I can find out
more and then you know I've got your
input and your ideas we'd all know the
types of categories we need to really
drill out and I'm going to reread the
bill based on now I'm thinking more
clearly on it hopefully all of us will
be able to do that representative Ulrich
yeah it's my understanding that uh
Tuesday is going to be the Overflow
plan on Thursdays being a long day just
because and that gets filled up it's
going to overflow backwards onto
Wednesday
and if Wednesday becomes a long day it's
going to overflow backwards on Tuesday
so it's not Tuesday's not the first day
Thursday's the first day and it backs up
that's the way that the
leadership is said it's going to go at
least that's my understanding
of course what they do I mean you know
so we I don't have any
decisions quite yet we'll have to see if
we can get a little bit more information
okay good and we'll we'll communicate as
best we can and uh I will definitely see
all of you on Wednesday
and if you think you know that morning
you're going to be a little late or
something let me know as soon as
possible yeah
uh thank you madam chair a question that
my mind I'm just wondering where the
room's at with this cannabis tax
and
if people would prefer if the room
prefers the 15
farmer tax
the meals and rooms tax at eight and a
half percent or the tobacco stamp tax
I mean it doesn't sound like they
considered that so I'm just kind of
curious where the room's at
so when I'm looking at this stuff
before I go to sleep tomorrow night or
tonight personally I am not prepared at
all to answer that question I didn't
think you were but I thought maybe more
of this but maybe other people want to
comment representative only yeah I think
that I want to look at a version of the
tobacco tax
we did a separate Vape tax thing and it
was put in very low because the Senate
insisted on it
produces practically no Revenue but um
we did do that and it's
enforced
by The Liquor Commission
and
um I think it could be in a good
alternative if we're looking at
some kind of a tax that's got several
levels to it and
and several rates to it
representative Spielberg
I I think that the closer we look
at the concept of taxing the ingredient
the raw material at the cultivation end
the more problematic it's going to be
and I I've been turning over in my mind
the timber analogy as well since I had
missed that one and uh you know I think
this is very different you're talking
about
trying to tax something that's an
ingredient that gets fashioned into many
different final forms I think we would
be far better off to look at a lower
rate on a final product and then all
those variables
basically work themselves into value
yes I agree we've done a lot of work
done on doing it at a wholesale level
there's a lot of buy-in on that but uh
I'm concerned about the 15 rate
other states have imposed taxes and fees
and made it legal but they had so many
taxes and fees that the illegal Market
hasn't gone away
and so I want to make it low enough
so that the illegal Market does go away
and we have people shopping from Maine
and Massachusetts into Vermont into New
Hampshire like we do with liquor and
that we might wind up with more Revenue
with a lower rate so I was thinking
somewhere in the eight percent range
wholesale yes
so so I was thinking so at first as the
discussion went on we heard from more
people I was in hearing particularly and
agreeing that sooner or later there's
going to be interstate commerce that we
needed to move something to the retail
level but one of the things I don't know
is I don't know we haven't heard anybody
talk about controlling the product like
along the path you know from the
cultivator to the top so maybe there
would be a need to track
what is cultivated here in New Hampshire
and goes up to up the next level and so
if you're going to do that and it needs
to be
you know some kind of
stamp put on it that you know we've
looked at this and we acknowledge that
this batch is going somewhere maybe a
very small fee or something just mostly
it's
it's kind of like the mushrooms the
mushrooms the wild mushrooms when
they're harvested they need to have a
code on them that will tell you where it
was harvested in by whom it was
harvested so there might be like some
kind of small processing fee to go to
that so I don't just want to ripe wipe
it off the books if we need it first for
chat tracking to make sure that the
product is safe
but overall I think it we mostly need to
focus on taxing at the retail level
the person Bolton did you have something
else yeah well since we're talking about
this and um and regarding the 15 fee I
don't think that's that's bad uh
considering the other states they
started out with like six or eight uh
for you know like a wholesale and then
10 or 12 for extra you know exercise I
mean it just kept on going up so 15 on
the wholesale basis does doesn't seem
that bad to me
but and again in anticipation of a
worldwide Market or at least uh United
States Market that should be considered
in the future I believe like it's too
much to think about at this point but
yes representative Malloy
so I know we're trying to talk about
Revenue here how much leeway do we have
for in the bill that's now in front of
us to change the model to another to go
to retail I mean this is policy or
Revenue I I'm I'm getting a little
confused here
I I just and we don't have to deal with
that today but I just don't know what is
policy now and what is revenue and and
how much we affect that
in this committee that's my I'm foggy
here
good question representative Olney
the bill deals with
with
um the Regis the registration of
retailers and the an enforcement that's
what the Liquor Commission is there for
the enforcement on retailers is more
what they've been thinking of and
forgetting the difficulty of of
enforcing on cultivators
when they are outside uh
but
um so
so putting the tax over at where it was
in the beginning at the retail level
uh isn't really a change in their policy
I think
they changed our policy why can't we
change in your back
that the other kind of answer to that is
that
tax policy is definitely in our Realm
and whether it's a wholesale base or
retail
taxes something we're entitled to make
choices on that as far as I'm concerned
yeah yeah and I if I can jump in I would
think that a retail base what about the
distributors
I mean if it gets taxed at the
distributor level
The Next Step I understand is the retail
level if we tax it at the distributor
level
wouldn't that cover all the bases would
avoid cheating
we can determine what the impact is on
the market that currently exists I don't
know
that sounds like that tracks more of the
um gas tax
and the tobacco tanks yes I think that's
a choice
but
but one one consideration for what you
just said though is we heard about that
vertical in integration that they can't
if it's one company doing all of it
right from the seed right up to the
retail where do they put the cut line
you know if you wanted you know
if if you're trying to tax the
distributor they're all of those things
so where do you
want to make this so I think that that
and that that was a question that I had
and I one that I think that if you're
vertically integrated and you're selling
cannabis from one entity to the other
for a dollar
right so you're if you charge it for a
dollar then you're gonna get 15 of the
dollar but then you got to realize that
that retail is going to make
an enormous amount of profit on
something they bought for a dollar so
we're gonna the state will not lose out
because we're going to get it and I
don't know the numbers I mean it but
integration
the vertical integration says it's all
one company one company puts the seed in
the ground grows it dries it they're all
owned by the same company but you're
going to have corporate divisions of
each of each thing why
well for one there'd be that licensing
component
well it's one company well it's like CBS
CBS owns the pharmacy they own the PBM
they own the insurer
but they're all three different
companies
and they all are taxed
separately well there's a variety of
taxes so CVS actually doesn't make a
difference whether they're separately
incorporated or a single corporate
entity that's that's beside the point
the real question is from point to point
what's the transfer pricing mechanism
and this is the question that
representative schanberg raised
if the settlement of the committee is to
move it to a distributor level which
would protect us partially about future
Federal uh legalization and cross-border
things into the distributed level the
rate has to come down because it's being
applied to a sale
price of a distributor rather than a
wholesaler so so no more than eight
percent of it's at a distributor level
all right you have lots to ponder and
read and learn I'm going to reread the
bill with a different set of eyes now
and take notes and then we will try to
find a date that works for everyone all
right be safe out there guys